FINANCE COMMITTEE.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OPEN AT
THAT MEETING IT WITH A ROLL CALL
PLEASE MESSENGER SIR.
HIGHER HERE WHY PRESENT MORLOCK
PRESENT OR NOT PRESENT NOW.
THE PRESENT HERTZBERG.
HELLO.
YEAH NIELSEN PRESENT WIENER.
WHEN A PRESIDENT?
THE GUY THAT PLAYS IN YOUR WE
ALREADY HAVE A QUORUM ESTABLISH
THANK YOU SO MUCH ISN'T QUICK
HOUSEKEEPING LAZY GENERALLY DO
NOT BUT CONSENT COUNTER HERE
TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE A HEADS UP
ABOUT OUR NEXT TWO WEEKS WE
ATTENDED TWELVE BILLS ALL
MEETING NEXT WEEK -- PLEASE PLAN
TO BE IN COMMITTEE UNTIL ABOUT
ONE OR ONE THIRTY IT NEXT WEEK
WELL THEY HAVE A MEETING THE
WEEK -- THE EIGHT ON JULY TENTH --
AND THAT WILL PROBABLY BE ABOUT
ANOTHER FIVE HOUR MEETING WE
WILL ALSO HAVE A COUPLE OF
HEARINGS AT LEAST IN AUGUST ON
OUR TAX LEVIES IS WELL.
FACING GENERALLY LIKE TO BE A TO
GET RIGHT INTO IT.
WE ARE GOING TO WELCOME THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN TO BE ABLE TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT ASSEMBLY
WOMAN RAISES HERE SOMEONE REYES
IS GOING TO PRISON TEEN ON AB.
TWO THIRTEEN TWO THIRTEEN WHICH
IS FOCUSED ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FINANCE.
DELIVER THE FLOOR IS YOURS IS
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB TWO THIRTEEN IS A MEASURE
BUILT ON FAIRNESS THAT WOULD
RESTORE REVENUES THAT PREVIOUSLY
WERE ALLOCATED TO CITIES THAT
ANNEXED INHABITED TERRITORIES.
AVENUES THAT WERE TAKEN AWAY.
BY THE PASSAGE OF SB EIGHTY NINE
AND TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN SB EIGHTY NINE A
PREVIOUS BUDGET TRAILER TRAILER
BILL WAS PASSED DURING STATE
BUDGET DIFFICULTIES.
THIS LEGISLATION IN EFFECT TOOK
AWAY TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
ANNUALLY IN VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
REVENUES FROM CITIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
AS A PART OF THIS CHANGE MANY OF
THESE AFFECTED.
MANY OF THOSE AFFECTED WERE
NEWLY INCORPORATED AREAS AND
CITIES WHO HAD ANNEXED.
NEW TERRITORIES THIS CALLS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ULTIMATELY LOSE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN REVENUE.
THERE ARE OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY CITIES.
THAT HAVE ANNEXED WHO HAVE LOST
REVENUE DUE TO THIS TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN LEGISLATION.
CITIES INCLUDE THE CITY OF
FONTANA IN MY DISTRICT.
WHICH LOSES APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. FOR ANNEXING CITIES
MANY OF WHICH ARE CURRENTLY CASH
STRAPPED TO THE LOSS OF THIS
CRITICAL SOURCE OF FUNDING HURTS
THE RESIDENTS.
CITIES PUT IN THIS POSITION
OFTEN MUST CUT CRITICAL SERVICES
SUCH S INVESTING AND LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE FOR WHAT
MANY CONSIDER TO BE AN
INCOMPLETE BUDGET.
ANOTHER PRACTICAL EFFECT OF
CURRENT LAW IS THE REDUCTION OF
INTEREST IN ANNEXATION.
GIVEN LIMITATIONS REGARDING NEW
REVENUE THE CITIES ARE NO LONGER
ABLE TO OBTAIN.
THE REVENUE AS A RESULT OF SB
EIGHTY NINE THE CITY IS NOW ARM
LESS LIKELY. TO ANNEX BECAUSE
THIS IS SUCH A BURDEN SOME
EFFORT.
WE DON'T GIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR RESIDENTS WE ARE
ACTIVELY CREATING A DISINCENTIVE
FOR ANNEXATION.
WEMUST EMPOWER OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
WE REVIEW INDIVIDUALS TO TESTIFY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
MY JOINT AUTHOR IS IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE SO SHE ASKED THAT I
SENT -- HER REGARDS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHRISTY SMITH WHO HAS
SOME CITIES ALSO OF WHO ARE
LOSING THE REVENUE BECAUSE OF
THE OF THIS BILL -- BUT WITH US
TODAY OR DAN CARRIED WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE CITY OF
FONTANA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU GENTLEMAN
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE WE WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE SUMMER
WOMAN OF COURSE TO MISS SMITH IS
WELL FOR ALL THE WORK ON THIS
BILL.
SCARED FOR SOURCE OR TWO MINUTES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS SAID DAN CARRIED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CITIES.
THIS BILL IN THE AUTHOR'S
STATEMENT -- WAS QUITE A
COMPREHENSIVE IN TERMS OF
COVERING THE ISSUES BUT REALLY
DEALS WITH TWO THINGS ONE IT'S
ADDRESSING AN INEQUITY -- AND
THE SECONDIS REESTABLISHING
WHAT IS -- WHAT WE PREFER
PREVIOUSLY HAD BEEN GOOD POLICY --
IN THIS STATE A LOT OF IT FORMED
BY THIS COMMITTEE IN THE PAST
RELATED TO ANNEXATION ABOUT HOW
TO HOW TO DEAL WITH GROWTH GOING
FORWARD.
SO IN TERMS OF THE INEQUITY ON
IS THE AUTHOR SAID -- THERE WERE
A A MANY COMMUNITIES THAT -- IN
ORDER OPINION HAD GONE OUT AND
DONE THE RIGHT THING THEY HAD A
BROUGHT IN -- IN -- IN ANNEXED
INHABITED AREAS OFTEN THESE
AREAS -- MAYBE HAVE -- THEIR
COUNTY ON A CORPORATE OR IS THEY
MIGHT HAVE LESS -- ADEQUATE
INFRASTRUCTURE -- IN SERVICES
AND SO BY BRINGING THESE
COMMUNITIES -- INTO THE CITY AND
SERVING THEM THAT THE CITY WOULD
BE TAKING ON ADDITIONAL SERVICE
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT ALSO
PROVIDING HAVE SERVICES TO THE
RESIDENT.
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH LOTS OF
CORE OF OTHER POLICIES A STATUS
VOTERS ON RELATED TO TRYING TO
IMPROVE OUR WATER QUALITY OF
SERVICES TO UNINCORPORATED AREAS
DEALING WITH THE ISSUES WITH
DISADVANTAGED ON A CORPORATE
REYES X. ULTRA.
SO THOSE CITIES ONE OUT IN OUR
OPINION DID THE RIGHT POLICY
THING BY BY BRINGING IN IN
SERVING THESE AREAS AND IN IN
PART OF THE WAY THOSE PENCIL OUT
WAS IN RELIANCE UPON THESE
REVENUES THAT THAT EXISTED.
SO -- AS THE AUTHOR SAID A BILL
WENT THROUGH NO HEARINGS NOTHING --
WIPED OUT THOSE THOSE FUNDS AND
SOME OF OF OUR CITIES FONTANA
AND OTHERS LOST A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY OF THAT THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE THERE TO SERVE
THOSE COMMUNITIES.
I WOULD JUST POINT OUT ANOTHER
CITY THAT IS -- WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED WAS THE
CITY OF CHICO -- WHICH IT HAD IT
HAD A LOT OF UNINCORPORATED
ISLANDS WITHIN THE CITY AND I
THINK IN THE PAST WAS ACTUALLY
ARE ECOGNIZED AND PRAISED.
FOR WORKING WITH LASKO IN AND
BRING IN A LOT OF THESE ISLANDS
AND AS YOU ALL KNOW -- CHICO'S
BASICALLY THE BASE CAMP FOR THE
THE RIGHT REBUILDING OF PARADISE
AND IS IN CURRENT A LOT OF
ADDITIONAL A COST ASSOCIATED
WITH SO THE THE IF THE FIXING
THIS INEQUITY IS IS A IS A GOOD
GOOD THING IT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO FIXED -- THERE
WERE FOUR INCORPORATED CITIES
THAT ALSO HAD BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
HARM THE LEGISLATURE FIX THAT
ISSUE TWO YEARS AGO THIS IS THE
SAME FIX.
I ENDED UP FOR FOR THE CITY'S AT
ANNEX THE SECOND THING I WOULD
SAY IS ON ON ON ON YES I KNOW
I'M RIGHT NEAR THE EDGE THERE
MISTER CHAIR.
ON THE RE ESTABLISHING GOOD
POLICY GOING FORWARD WE ALL KNOW
THE STATE IS GOING TO GROW WE
ALL KNOW THAT -- IT'S IMPORTANT
THERE ARE ALL SORTS OF GROWTH
POLICIES THAT THE STATE WANTS TO
OUR PROMOTE THAT TRIES TO A
CONCENTRATE GROWTH IN IN IN IN
DENSITIES IN IN URBAN AREAS
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF REASONS FOR
THAT.
REESTABLISHING OUR ANNEXATION
INCENTIVES GOING FORWARD WE
THINK IS ALSO GOOD POLICY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SO MUCH
SKERIK GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN IN
MINUTES AS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHASING AND SOLVE THIS
REPRESENTING THE CITIES OF
MONTANA CAMARILLO.
SANTA CLARITA AND SAN BERNARDINO
AND JUST VERY BRIEFLY -- FOR THE
CITY OF FONTANA ANTIQUATED TO
ABOUT SIX OR SEVEN POLICE
OFFICERS -- THIS BILL WOULD
RESTORE THAT FOR THE PUBLIC
SAFETY NEEDS AND WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE OFFER THE AUTHOR
FOR DOING SO SENATE CREATE IS
ABOUT THREE OR FOUR POLICE
OFFICERS AND THAT'S REALLY WHERE
THEY WERE THEY CUTS -- ME THE
MOST OF THIS TAKES CARE THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT A WEEK
WE THANK BOTH OFF AUTHORS FOR
THEIR EFFORTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH GRATEFUL FOR JUST
LIABILITY THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE NOT AN OPEN IT UP FOR
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT FIRST AND LAST.
NAME AS WELL AS ORGANIZATION WE
WELCOME LACK OF THE TABLE.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PAMELA
MILLER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSIONS.
YOU KNOW I IF YOU'RE TO INDULGE
ME FOR JUST A MOMENT PLEASE
MISTER CHAIR I WAS HERE LAST
WEEK AND WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
ANNEXATIONS AND SENATOR HER
TITLE BROUGHT UP.
AS DID SENATOR MORE LOCK THE
LACK OF A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
FOR CITIES TO ANNEX TERRITORY.
AND A SENSE THIS AND FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE WAS TAKEN AWAY LAUGH
BECAUSE OF ACTUALLY SEEN A
SUBSTANTIAL DECREASE AT ABOUT
HALF THEIR PROCESSING ABOUT HALF
OF THE ANNEXATIONS THAT THEY USE --
TO IT'S CRITICAL TO THE ORDERLY
GROWTH AND LOGICAL BOUNDARIES
AND THE EFFICIENT PROVISION OF
LOCAL SERVICES.
COLUSA DID AN ANNEXATION DUE TO
WATER CONCERNS THE WHICH BECAUSE
THE CITY OF COLUSA SOMEA
REVENUE SHORTAGES.
AND ANOTHER EXAMPLE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN CONTRA COSTA
LEFT APROVED EIGHT INHABITED
ANNEXATIONS ONE WAS AN
UNINCORPORATED ISLAND CONSIDERED
A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY WITH
ALL OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES
RELATED TO THOSE DISADVANTAGED
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES.
AND NO FUNDING -- TO MAKE THOSE
CORRECTIONS SIMILAR STORIES AND
KERN SAN MATTEO CENTER AND OTHER
COUNTIES.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
SMALLER IT'S ALWAYS GOOD HAVING
COMMITTEE IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
EXPIRY WITH CITY OF RIVERSIDE
ALSO IN SUPPORT EXPECTS CHRISSY.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MR CHECK YOUR ROSS
ON BEHALF OF THE MARIN COUNTY
COUNCIL MAYORS AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE GOOD MORNING
SIR.
MORNING KIRK OF L. SYMBOLS AND
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY'S
UP TO MACULAR EN EL CENTRO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE A
RECEIPT THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM.
YOU'RE NOT POSITION IF YOU
PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME
[inaudible]
LAST CALL.
THE THREE BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MISTER BELIN MR MEISTER -- JUSTO
SO WE'RE WE'RE THIS IS -- THE
BILL THAT WOULD -- TAKE MONEY
FROM THE E. RAF.
THE PROPERTY TAX.
AND AND IT BE BACK FILLED BY THE
GENERAL FUND IS THAT CORRECT.
YES SENATOR OF IT'S IT'S THE
SAME EXACT FORMULA THAT WAS USED
OF FOR THE FOUR INCORPORATED
CITIES -- IT YES IT WOULD IT
WOULD -- AS THE CHAIR AS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED -- THERE WERE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TAKEN AWAY FROM A FROM CITIES --
IN THIS THE THE I THINK THE COST
OF THIS BILL IN THE ASSEMBLY WAS
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO FIX IT.
AND THERE THE OTHER OTHER CITIES
THERE'D BE ON OUT THAT ARE.
IN THE SAME BOAT THAT WE KNOW OF
OR WOULD THEY BE MORE CITIES.
THE ON OUT OF THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED FORTY
CITIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THAT WILL BE AFFECTED THAT HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED BY.
BY THIS AND WILL THIS WILL
REMEDY.
THOUGH SOMEWHAT HELPFUL.
ABSOLUTELY WOULD HELP ALL OF THE
ROOMS WORRISOME OKAY IT DIDN'T
INCREASES WAS REMINDED US SAN
JOSE THE CITY OF SAN JOSE I
BELIEVE TO THE SAME THING AN
EXTRA NUMBER OF VIOLENCE AND I
THINK THE IT WAS FOR AROUND.
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR SOME THEY LOST WHEN SB
EIGHTY NINE WENT THROUGH SO THAT
THAT WOULD BE RESTORED GOING
FORWARD TO THAT SAN JOSE CA.
LIKE -- THIS IS HE WRAPPED
ALREADY WRAPPED TICKETS. TO THE
CITY COFFERS AND THAT'S BACK
FILLED BY THE STATE YES YES SIR.
YEAH -- HAS THERE BEEN ANY
OPPOSITION.
OF FROM GROUPS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
RATHER EDUCATIONAL GROUPS NO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS CENTER WE
KNOW LIKE TURNED OVER TO THE
VICE CHAIR ONE IS FRESHER.
SO YOUR USER.
HEY THERE YOU GO.
IT IS HE OF YES REDUCE AFTER A
CALL BUT IF I WOULD HAVE.
READ THIS BEFORE OUR PHONE CALL
LAST NIGHT AND IT GIVE YOU A
LITTLE MORE.
INPUT BUT SB EIGHTY NINE WHICH
IS BEING CORRECTED HERE ARE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WAS NEFARIOUS
AND IT WAS.
A BUDGET TRAILER BILL THAT JUST
WIPED OUT A LOT OF US.
INCLUDING THAT THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE SO I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
WHETHER THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE RIGHT.
ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE BILL LINES
THIRTY ONE THROUGH -- FORTY
THERE THERE'S A REFERENCE THERE
AND I'M JUST WONDERING YOUR YOU
KEPT USING THE TERM CITIES.
BUT IS THE COUNTY OF ORANGE
BEING -- ADDRESSED AS WELL
BECAUSE WE TOOK -- AS IT SAYS IN
THE BILL OF FIFTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR YET. TO OUR
GENERAL FUND IT WAS IT WAS AWFUL
AND THEY PUT ME IN LITIGATION I
WAS CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF THE
TIME AT IS TO GOVERNOR BROWN AND
IT'S JUST NOT A PLEASANT TIME.
IT IS SENATOR ODENKIRK WITH
LAWYER CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE THE
ANSWER IS NO WE DON'T BELIEVE
THE BILL AT ALL AFFECTS THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE IN FACT THE
COUNTY WARRANTS DID.
GET A FIX I THINK IT WAS A
SENATOR CORY A BILL NUMBER THREE
FOUR YEARS AGO AND AND THAT THAT
IS NOT A TOUCH BY THIS PROPOSAL --
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS A CAREER
AS YOU SAID A QUREIA BILL.
I BELIEVE WAS SENATOR KOREA --
IT THINK IT WAS PROBABLY FOUR
YEARS AGO.
WHEN THERE WASN'T MUCH OF A FIX
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OUR YARD AND JUST KIND OF
CURIOUS -- MAYBE MAYBE STAFF TO
GET BACK TO ME TO LET ME KNOW --
IF -- IF IF IF AT LEAST.
EQUITY HAS BEEN PROVIDED BECAUSE
I I I SUPPORTED EVERYONE OF
SENATOR ROSS BILLS -- EVERY YEAR
WHILE I WAS STILL SUPERVISOR AND
EVERY YEAR THEY WENT THROUGH.
THE LEGISLATURE GOT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND GOVERNOR
BROWN BE TOLD THEM IT WASN'T
UNTIL. TWO YEARS AGO THAT THAT
LIKE ON THE THIRD ITERATION THAT
THE GOVERNOR FINALLY SIGNED THE
BILL.
BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE IS.
TREATED AS EQUITABLY AS ALL THE
CITIES AND AND WE HAD SEVEN
WORKING HARD FOR THE FOUR CITIES.
IN IN YOUR DISTRICT -- TO MAKE
SURE THEY GOT THEIR BILLS.
I JUST BRING THAT UP RICHARD
SHARPE WE CANNOT THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO COMMENT I DO WANT TO
SAY THEY WERE.
NOT TO BE SENT IN MY DISTRICT --
THEY WORD SENATOR ROTH'S WITCHES
ON NEIGHBORING -- COMMUNITY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE CITIES
WHO HAVE ALREADY DONE THE WORK
OF ANNEXING.
THE PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
WOULD HAVE RECEIVED THAT FUNDING
FROM THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE WAY -- THE
LEGISLATION THE TRAILER BILL WAS
WRITTEN THEY NO LONGER RECEIVE
THIS.
SO IT IS.
AND WE DO HAVE A LIST OF THE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY PLUS CITIES
THAT WILL BENEFIT BECAUSE OF
THIS I'M WITH YOU AND AND IT
AFFECTED CITIES THAN NEXT AFTER.
TWO THOUSAND FOUR AND AFTER TWO
THOUSAND FOR THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE.
REFINANCE STAR BANKRUPTCY DEBT.
AND THE WILL OF THE BOOK THE
BORROWERS WANTED AS A DEDICATED
INCOME STREAM SO WE USE THE VLF
REVENUE STREAM AS THE SOURCE TO
PAY THE BONDS.
AND SO IN THE INDENTURE WHEN WE
REFUNDED REFINANCED WE HAD TO
SAY WERE STILL USING THE BOS
SOURCE ALTHOUGH IT WAS OUR
PROPERTY TAXES GOING IN THERE
BECAUSE IT ALL BEEN.
CHANGED BECAUSE OF A SWAB THAT
OCCURRED DURING THE ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER MINISTRATIONS SO
IT WAS A CONTRIVANCE.
BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN OUR MONEY
OUR FIFTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
GOT CAUGHT UP IN SB EIGHTY NINE
AND IT WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM US --
SO IT WAS EXTREMELY AWKWARD
BECAUSE ALL WE WERE DOING WAS
MEETING -- A BONDHOLDER
REQUIREMENT WHEN WE REFINANCE SO
WE KIND OF GOT CAUGHT IN THIS
UGLY MASS.
AND ND WHO KNOWS IF IT WAS
INTENTIONAL OR NOT -- BUT IT WAS --
NOT A PLEASANT EXPERIENCE SO I'M
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
NOW THAT WERE HEALING ALL THESE
WOUNDS.
TECH IS WE DO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION LAST WEEK ABOUT WHY
IN COURT Y. Y. ANNEX PARCELS IN
IRELAND'S IF YOU'RE GOING.
TO YOU KNOW HAVE A NET NEGATIVE
SO AFTER EVER DOING THAT I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE IF YOU KNOW THE
DAY THAT THE COUNTY OF ORANGE IS
ALSO BEEN.
TREATED AS EQUITABLY AS EVERYONE
ELSE ON OUR SUPPORT THE BILL
I'VE I'VE BEEN THERE I JUST.
WHAT I MAKE SURE I'M ONE OF
THOSE NO BETTER NO WORSE
EVERYBODY ELSE SHOULD BE TO SEE
TREATED THE SAME WAY?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH MOTION FOR BY CENTER OF
BALANCE -- IT THANKS TO THE
RESEARCH -- MISTER PETERSON --
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THERE WAS
A ONE TIME ADJUSTMENT AND THE B.
L. AFTER ORANGE COUNTY WORTH
ABOUT FIFTY THREE MILLION.
SO THAT WAS -- WITH ONE TIME
YEAH.
BUT WHAT WE'LL DO SOME
ADDITIONAL DIG IN AND GET BACK
IS WELL SO WE DO HAVE A FOLLOW
UP ON THE SIDE IN THE FOLLOW UP.
IS BEING ABLE THAT I GET SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. FOR THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE ON THIS ITEM.
THE MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE
A CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TO THE WE CAN BRING EQUITY TO
THOSE CITIES.
THAT HAVE LOST FOR SO MANY YEARS
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE CONVERSATION
BY THE COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A
PROMOTION ON THE FLOOR THIS
MOTION IS A DO PASSIVE
PREPARATIONS BY SENATOR BAO.
ISN'T USER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
HI.
I'M MORE LOCK MORE LUCK I DOUBT
THEY'LL AYE HERTZBERG BRITTONUM.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER WIENER I IT
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
VOTE SOME NEVER REALLY NICE WORK
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S ALWAYS A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER.
BUT IN GENERAL WE'RE NOW MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER ONE THIS IS AB
ONE THIRTY SIX MISS QUIRK SORROW
SILVA.
SHE'S FOCUSING ON ISSUES OF
PERSONAL INCOME DEFICIT INCOME
TAX LAW CAN'T SPEAK YOUR TODAY.
THE NUMBER YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
HI DAY.
HI SO WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
PRESENTATION WE WELCOME YOU BACK
TO COMMITTEE TWO WEEKS IN A ROW
QUIRK SILVA IS HERE AND READY TO
GO.
I WILL SPEND AS LITTLE TIME AS I
CAN AND COMMITTEE.
A WITH DAVID THANK YOU MISTER
NELSON -- ANYHOW WE DO HAVE A
BILL AB ONE THIRTY SIX AND THIS
IS A PACKAGE OF BILLS BY OTHER
COLLEAGUES RELATED TO THE
COLLEGE.
ADMISSIONS SCANDAL AND WE WOULD
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU KNOW YOU
ARE GONNA BE TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS AS WELL YES THANK YOU.
VERY GRATEFUL AND LOOK AT THE
SIMILAR MEANS IN WORKING HARD ON
THIS ISSUE THERE IS A SERIES OF
BILLS THAT ARE MOVING FORWARD
THROUGH THIS.
IS SIMPLY RIGHT NOW IN JUST ONE
TAKE MOM TO ACKNOWLEDGE HER --
BECAUSE IT IS JUST BEING A
CRISIS AND SO MANY FAMILIES
BECAUSE OF THAT SO THANK YOU SO
ISSUE AS QUIRK SILVA.
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU ALL WOULD LIKE TO
BECOME FORT FOR THE CAN FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
WHERE DO A LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT
NOT GONNA ASK FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION?
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR IT
WITH EMOTION THE FLOORS IS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED BY TWO SENATE
CORPORATIONS BY MISTER BELL
WOULD LIKE TO TURN OVER THE VICE
CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER -- I APPRECIATE
THIS BILL AND WHAT IT'S TRYING
TO DO -- WHAT MISTER SINGER IS
DONE AS THIS CREATED A REAL
STAIN ON THE UC SYSTEM I JUST
REALLY [inaudible]
AWFUL AND UNITED ROB HAVE PLENTY
OF PARENTS HAVE COME TO US IN
TEARS HOW COME MY SON OR MY
DAUGHTER.
WITH A FOUR POINT THREE CAN'T
GET INTO A UC'S YOU KNOW CAMPUS.
AND HERE'S PEOPLE GETTING IN
[inaudible]
FRAUDULENTLY SO.
I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS ABOUT TWO
THINGS ONE AM WE JUST ASK FOR
DIANE AT FTP BUT DO WHO'S OUR
NEW DIANNE.
FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD WE
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD [inaudible]
THAT'S RICH.
WE HAVE A IS CARLSON I BELIEVE
IS HERE.
THIS CROSS AND COME ON DOWN.
WE WELCOME YOU.
WE ALWAYS I DON'T HAVE TO BE IS
IN THE HOUSE.
COME ON UP TO THE TABLE.
THE NAME WAS CARL.
JENNIFER YES PLEASE RIGHT
THERE'S GREAT.
WITH CARLSON -- YOU KNOW NOT TO
REVEAL ANY FTP SECRETS BUT YOU
KNOW WHEN WHEN SOMETHING LIKE
THIS A NONPROFIT GETS IN THE
NEWS IS THAT SORT OF A TRIGGER
FOR YOU.
TO AND YOUR YOUR DEPARTMENT SAID
TODAY TO REVIEW.
AT THE NONPROFIT THE NINE NINETY
IS THAT THE ONE NINETY NINES AND
THEN BUT ALSO TO TO LOOK AT YOU
KNOW MAYBE MAJOR DONORS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO BE LISTED AS WELL
UP THERE LIKE MORE THAN 5% RIGHT
UP THE REVENUES.
IS THAT IS THAT.
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD
NATURALLY GO BOY WE BETTER START
AUDITING HERE.
IT'S CROSSING BEFORE YOU BEGIN
IF YOU CAN JUST GIVE US YOUR
FIRST AND LAST IN YOUR TITLE IN
ORGANIZATION WE WELCOME YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YES YOU'RE GOOD.
JENNA CRLSON ACTING LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK GOOD TO SEE.
SENATOR THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD USES THAT
MANY MANY SOURCES OF INFORMATION.
TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL NON
COMPLIANCE.
AND THE PUBLIC MEDIA IS ONE OF
THEM.
SO WE'RE WE'RE FOCUSED JUST ON
ONE'S BUT THIS PARTICULAR
NONPROFIT BUT I'M I'M WONDERING --
IT IS -- WAVE MAYBE IN IT OR
MAYBE A READY IN CODE IS -- WITH
A WHOLE.
THE STATUE OF LIMITATIONS OR
WITH THE FACT THAT MAYBE THERE'S
FRAUD INVOLVED.
WITH THAT REMOVED THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
THERE ARE STATUTES TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO FRAUDULENT
ACTIVITY HOWEVER I WOULD NOTE
THAT.
IF THERE IS A LACK OF DON'T
ACTIVE INTENT. FOR A
CONTRIBUTION.
THAT CURRENT LAW ALLOWS FOR THE
DISALLOWANCE OF A CHARITABLE
CONTRIBUTION DEDUCTION
[inaudible]
SO.
IF IF IF ONE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS AS EITHER --
ADMITTED GUILT AND DOESN'T GO
THROUGH TRIAL BAR IS FOUND
GUILTY AFTER TRIAL -- AND THEY
MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS AND DOUBTS
NOW THE DEEMED FRAUDULENT THEN
WITH THIS BILL BE NECESSARY OR
OR OR OR THE CURRENT.
PROCESS SEES ALREADY GOING TO
SATISFY WHAT WE WHAT WE REALLY
WANT TO DO HERE.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION AND THAT
REALLY SPEAKS MORE THE INTENT --
UNDER CURRENT LAW FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD DOES HAVE THE AUTHORITY.
TO CORRECT THE TAX BENEFIT OR
REVERSE THE TAX BENEFIT THAT WAS
TAKEN THAT DID NOT MEET THE
UNDERLYING CODE.
SO THERE'S NOT A BILL OF TODAY
WHERE YOU HAVE A TWENTY YEAR
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS IS THAT
CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY SO THEN.
I'M I'M JUST YOU KNOW I WANT TO
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THIS IS THIS IS THE TOPIC OF THE
DAY AND IRONICALLY MR SINGERS
CONSTITUENT OF MINE -- BUT JUST
YOU KNOW I'M FRUSTRATED BY IT
ALL BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO DO A BILL
EVERY TIME WE SEE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS THAT IT'S READY.
HOPEFULLY SOMETHING IN PLACE
THAT WOULD.
TAKE CARE OF EGREGIOUS EVENTS
LIKE THIS.
AND IT WOULD ALL THIS TO YOU IS
IS THAT ON HERE IN IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT WAS ADVANCED BY
FTP -- IN A READING STRAIGHT
FROM THE ANALYSIS OF THE
TAXPAYER DID NOT FILE A TAX
RETURN -- PILES OF FALSE OR
FRAUDULENT TAX RETURN.
THERE IS NO TIME LIMIT IF TO BE
TO ASSESS TAX SO -- PLEASE -- IN
HAVE YOU CONCLUDE HIS CROSS IN
THE NECK TO BE WOULD HAVE THAT
SIMPLY WOMAN BE ABLE TO OFFER A
CLOSING COMMENT AS WELL PLEASE.
BUT I WOULD SAY -- SENATOR AGAIN
GREAT QUESTIONS AND CURRENT LAW
DOES ALLOW FOR THE CORRECTION OF
A CLAIM TO TAX BENEFIT THAT DID
NOT MEET THE UNDERLYING
REQUIREMENTS OF THE CODE.
THANK YOU MISS CAROL WELCOME.
YOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
SIMONE WE'D LIKE TO BE AT OFFER
CLOSE PLEASE -- JUST RESET IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS SIMPLY
WOMEN OF WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR THIS IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SO SENATE
PREPARATIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TO SENATOR BELL.
MISSING CHESTERTON PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
HI.
I'M MORE LOCKED MORE LUCK I DOWN
BILL I HEARD.
HER TITLE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER WIENER AYE
FUNDS.
THE CURRENT ENJOYS A FIVE EIGHT
ZERO VOTE.
SOON WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN IN ADD ON AS FOLKS COMING
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU.
THANK YOU BACK NEXT WEEK.
WE'LL SEE IT NOW ALL RIGHT.
I THINK HE PRETTY MUCH SAID HELL
NO -- SO OKAY.
PLEASE IN GENERAL WE HAVE
RELIGION HERE WITH US TO THE
CHAIR WOMAN FROM EVAN TAX.
THIS IS AB TWO SIXTY THREE CHAIR
WOMAN BURKE.
MADAM CHAIR THIS DOES ENJOY
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT -- SO WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT THE FLOOR
IS YOURS AND WELCOME THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND THINK YOU
AT CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS I WANT
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS TO EXTEND THE
PROVISION OF THIS BILL TO SALES
AND USE TAX LAW AS WELL.
AB TWO SIXTY THROUGH EXPAND THE
EXISTING REQUIREMENT UNDER
REVENUE AND TAXATION CODE
SECTION. FORTY ONE TO ALL TAX
EXPENDITURES UNDER THE PERSONAL
INCOME TAX LAW AND CORPORATION
TAX LAW.
THIS INCLUDES ALL TAX CREDITS
DEDUCTIONS EXEMPTIONS INCLUSIONS
AND ANY OTHER TAX BENEFIT
PROVIDED BY THE STATE.
IN GENERAL EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
THAT ALL NEW TAX CREDITS CONTAIN
A SPECIFIC GOAL PURPOSE AN
OBJECTIVE ALONG WITH DETAILED
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS.
WE THINK THAT HAVING THIS
INFORMATION ALLOWED TO
LEGISLATURE TO BETTER EVALUATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF TAX CREDITS
WHICH IS WHY WOULD THAT THIS
BILL WORK SEEKING TO EXPAND
THOSE REQUIREMENTS TO ALL TAX
EXPENDITURES -- WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION JENNIFER BAKER TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH SHOWING HIS BAKER WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE THIS
DOES ENJOY.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT YOU DO HAVE
UP TO TWO MINUTES [inaudible]
THE ACTUALLY [inaudible]
WE DID -- THAT.
WE CAN GET FROM.
AND TO MEASURES THAT HAVE BEEN
CREATED PRIOR TO A WHEN WE BEGAN
HAVING -- MEASURES FOR EFFICACY
BUT WERE EXTREMELY.
PROUD TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS ACTUALLY
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL SUNSHINE AND
TRANSPARENCY NOT TO HOW
CALIFORNIA SPENDING IT'S TAX
DOLLARS AND WE ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS BAKER WE
NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN IT UP ANYONE ELSE AND
SUPPORTED YOU CAN PLEASE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE RIGHT OVER HERE.
YOU CAN GIVE US YOUR FIRST
LASSEN ORGANIZATION WE WELCOME
YOU CAN MEDIAN TAKE MORNING.
THE MORNING REGARDING EARLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING IN THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME
MORNING IN.
THE MORNING SURELY DOWN WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANKS FOR
BEING HERE.
LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT.
WE NOW TO OPEN UP FOR THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR
BELL THIS IS DO PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
LIKELY TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS.
THE VICE CHAIR.
HEY SEE THERE YOU GO WATCH OUT.
HERE IS YOU KNOW -- FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
WE'D LIKE TO TURN OVER THE CHAIR
WOMAN TO BE ABLE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIRMAN AND THE
SENATORS THANK YOU I I'M WE'RE
HAPPY WE HAVE HAD BY BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I JUST THINK THIS IS
GOOD GOVERNANCE.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN ABLE THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
CHAIR AT YOUR WONDERFUL TO WORK
WITH ALONG WITH YOUR ENTIRE
COMMITTEE STAFF SO THANKS TO ALL
OF YOU FOR BEING HERE THINK SO
MUCH AS BAKER.
WE CAN'T ROLL CALL PLEASE --
MISSING JESTER WIRE HI WHERE I
AM OR NOT MORE LIKE I HERTZBERG FURTADO
[inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER [inaudible]
I WITH THE CLIFFHANGER BUT IS
THERE WE GO THANK YOU SO MUCH AT
AND YOU'RE GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
BECAUSE FOR WE'RE NOT GONNA
WELCOME.
MR MEDINA UP THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
SIX ON YOUR AGENDA.
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE THE
NUMBER YOU ENJOY BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IT'S LIKE A GROUP FIST
BUMP TODAY SO IT'S GOOD STUFF.
WE WELCOME THE SIM NUMBER ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL WANT TO SAY
THANK IT IS A MEMBER FOR ALL OF
HIS WORK.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WHICH MEANS
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
VERSION OF YOUR TESTIMONY THE
NUMBER THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- TODAY I PRESENT
AB.
EIGHT FOUR EIGHTY FIVE I WANT TO
NOTE AN ERROR IN THE MAN'S IN
SECTION.
FIVE THREE ZERO EIGHT THREE
POINT ONE SUBSECTION DE.
THE FIRST NUMBER.
SEVEN WAS MET TO BE REMOVED Vì
AND AN AGREEMENT WE HAD WITH THE
OPPOSITION.
AND WILL BE CORRECTING THAT
ERROR WITH AMENDMENTS IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE.
WORK.
AB FOR EIGHTY FIVE IS A
TRANSPARENCY BILL AIMED AT
HOLDING COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE TO
PROMISES MADE WHEN THEY WERE
ASKING FOR SUBSIDIES.
IT IS A COMMON SENSE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS THAT GOOD FOR
WORKERS TAXPAYERS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IS CAITLYN VEGA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
ANGIE MAREADY REPRESENTING THE
MAYOR OF FRESNO.
MEDINA THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
ALWAYS ENJOY A HAVE BEEN
MISTAKEN IS READY IN COMMITTEE
MISTAKE OF THE FLOOR IS YOURS MR
CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN BACK A FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
A PROUD TO BE SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE.
I FIRST MET A MANY OF THE
WAREHOUSE WORKERS ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO WITH THE WAREHOUSE
WORKERS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
I LEARNED THAT THERE WERE OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND WORKERS ALMOST
ALL OF THEM HIRED AS TEMPORARY
WORKERS.
WORKING ALMOST AS DAY LABORERS
WHERE THEY HAD TO SHOW UP EACH
DAY GET IN LINE SEE WHETHER THEY
WERE CHOSEN THEY WERE WORKING
UNDER SOME OF THE MOST
OPPRESSIVE CONDITIONS I HAVE
EVER HEARD.
OF INCLUDING -- PREGNANT WOMEN
HAVING TO LIFT HEAVY CRATES NO
PROTECTION AGAINST EXTREME HEAT
NO REST PERIODS -- THOUGH THEY
WERE SHOCKING CONDITIONS AND THE
WORKER STARTED TO COME OUT AND
SPEAK TO THOSE CONDITIONS.
OVER THE YEARS WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
IS THAT THESE WAREHOUSE
OPERATORS MAKE PROMISES TO BRING
JOBS TO AREAS THAT BADLY NEED
THEM AND THEN INSTEAD OF USING
THOSE TAXPAYER SUBSIDIES TO
CREATE GOOD JOBS.
AND TO HELP BRING FAMILIES OUT
OF POVERTY THEY ARE USED -- TO
CREATE LOW WAGE TEMPORARY JOBS
WHERE WORKERS ARE OFTEN PAID A
GROUP PIECE RATE AND MAKE VERY
LITTLE MONEY WHERE THERE'S
HIGHER.
RATES OF WAGE THEFT AND WORKER
INJURIES THE GOAL OF THIS BILL
IS SIMPLE IT IS TRANSPARENCY
TELL US THE KINDS OF JOBS YOU'RE
GOING TO CREATE -- BE CLEAR WHAT
THE DEAL IS YOU'RE MAKING WITH
THE LOCAL -- WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND BE TRUE TO YOUR
WORK THAT'S ALL THIS BILL ASKS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS ANTI
MINETTI HERE ON BEHALF OF
MERRILY BRAND WITH THE CITY OF
FRESNO WANTED -- TO AT PRIOR TO
THIS -- WE WERE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED AND WANTED THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND THE
SPONSOR FOR WORKING WITH US.
I TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS --
FRESNO HAS -- SEVERAL TAX
SHARING AGREEMENTS IN PRIOR TO
THE MAYOR BECOMING -- PRIOR TO
MERELY BRAND ASSUMING -- OFFICES
MAYOR HE HAD PASSED THE ECONOMIC
EXPANSION ACT WHICH ANTICIPATED
THE CHALLENGES -- WE WOULD FACE
IN OFFERING THESE INCENTIVES
AGREEMENT SO THEREFORE -- LEND
ITSELF TO ADDING INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
FOR THESE SHARING AGREEMENTS --
WE BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE IS A STRONG MEASURE
WHICH CONTINUES TO PRESERVE THIS
VALUABLE ECONOMIC -- DEVELOPMENT
TOOL BUT STILL STRIKE THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE FOR US.
TO ENSURE THAT RETAILERS -- ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND ARE
PROVIDING THE RIGHT KINDS OF
JOBS THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IN OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH WITH
MANET'S WONDERING WHO THE HELL
ON THIS MORETTI IS.
SO I THINK SO MUCH MANY VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY ANSWER THAT I PUT YOUR
LAST NAME.
SO IF YOUR EGO THANK YOU WHEN I
CAN OPEN IT UP FOR THOSE WHO MAY
BE IN SUPPORT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
PERSON LASSEN ORGANIZATIONS
COULD YOU SISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MAP ROUTE WITH THE TEAMSTERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU YOU SEE A
SATYR POPS.
GOOD MORNING I DON'T.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I AM WELL
CHRISTY VELMA BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
IN MY POPS IS GOOD ALSO A THERE
YOU GO I LIKE IT IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IF ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NOW GOING TO TURN OVER
OPPOSITION.
MORNING MR SURELY IS OVER THERE
WITH CAL CHAMBER WITH POLICE TO
REMOVE OPPOSITION AFTER THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHTS ORGANIZED.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHASING AND
SALAS REPRESENTING THE CITY
MARINO VALLEY -- WE HAVE A
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
WE DID THE PRIOR VERSION THAT
WAS VETOED WITH ME I HAVE THE
VICE MAYOR -- VICTORIA BACCHUS
TO MAKE A BRIEF FOR A FEW BRIEF
COMMENTS IF YOU WILL THANK YOU
GREAT.
ADVICE VERY WELCOMING COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE
TIME IN YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE TO BE
WITH US YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES ME
ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND AND I
REALLY -- I'M HONORED TO BE HERE
THINK OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO READ
THE STATEMENT PLEASE --
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS PLAY A
PIVOTAL ROLE IN THE MOVEMENT OF
GOODS AND CALIFORNIA AND HELP
SOLIDIFY OUR STATE'S ROLE AS THE
GATEWAY FOR COMMERCE.
SINGLING THEM OUT ONLY MAKES IT
MORE COMPELLING FOR THESE
BUSINESSES TO BUILD IN OTHER
STATES CALIFORNIA.
DOESN'T DEMAND THIS LEVEL OF
SCRUTINY WITH OTHER PROMINENT
INDUSTRY SUCH AS HIGH TECH FILM
SPORTS ARENAS AND ENTERTAINMENT
VENUES.
CURRENT LAW ALREADY REQUIRES
SUBSTANTIAL DISCLOSURE AB FORTY
FIVE CONTAINS POISON PILL
PROVISIONS THAT WOULD REQUIRE
DISCLOSURE BUSINESS INFORMATION
THAT IS STRICTLY PROPRIETARY.
MY STAFF SURVEYED SEVERAL OF
ORINDA VALLEY'S LOGISTIC
COMPANIES MANY ARE FORTUNE.
FIVE HUNDRED AND INTERNATIONAL
COMPANIES WILL CONTINUE TO
CONFIRM THAT THIS INFORMATION
WOULD NEVER BE PROVIDED FOR
PUBLICATION THESE REQUIREMENTS
WOULD ONLY MAKE THE BUSINESS
CLIMATE IN TEXAS AND MEXICO SEEM.
THAT MUCH MORE ALLURING.
MORENO VALLEY ASSERTS THAT THE
JOBS CREATED BY THE LOGISTICS
INDUSTRY BRING ECONOMIC
STABILITY TO FAMILIES WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE SUFFER FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT.
ACCORDING TO UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL
OF BUSINESS BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
TOTAL PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT IN THE
CITY INCREASED BY SIXTEEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY
JOBS.
OF WHICH THE TRANSPORTATION
WAREHOUSING AND UTILITIES
CATEGORY REPRESENT MORE THAN 61%
OF NEW JOBS CREATED.
MOST IMPRESSIVE IS THAT MARINO
VALLEY'S AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD
INCOME INCREASED FROM SIXTY
THREE THOUSAND TO OVER SEVENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WE HAVE WITNESSED OTHER STATES
OFFERING INCENTIVES TO LURE
COMPANIES OUT OF CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE DO NOT LIMIT THE FEW
TOOLS AT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CAN UTILIZE TO TRACK JOBS SO
THAT OUR RESIDENTS CAN HAVE A
PROSPEROUS ECONOMIC FUTURE.
A VOTE FOR A BEFORE EIGHTY FIVE
IS A VOTE FOR TEXAS AND MEXICO.
IN CLOSING AS MAYOR PRO TEM OF
THE CITY THAT S A TWENTY FIRST
LARGEST CITY IN CALIFORNIA WE
URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BETTER MAYOR PRO TEM THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE TWO
OF YOU STAY THERE -- HERE AS WE
PROCEED WITH ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION IF WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ANYONE ELSE COMPORT.
COMING LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JACK YOU'RE
GONNA BE HELPFUL YOU
CALIFORNIA'S CITIES EARLIER THIS
YEAR THIS COMMITTEE HEARD IN
PAST -- SENATOR GLAZERS SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE WHICH REALLY DEALT
WITH THE KEY ISSUE ASSOCIATED
WITH WERE HOUSES AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS THE SALES
TAX AGREEMENTS AND BASICALLY
PROHIBITED THESE.
AGREEMENTS GOING FORWARD -- WE
SEE -- WITH THIS BILL ELLIS --
CONTINUING THE MEMBERS HAVE GONE
OUT IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION BUT
CONTINUE TO IMPOSE ADDITIONAL
SET OF HOOPS AND HURDLES ON ONE
TYPE OF OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AS OPPOSED TO OTHERS AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE THINK SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM
IN THIS BILL GOES TOO FAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS CAN BE
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED LAST CALL.
AND BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
AND A TURN OVER THE SEVEN MEMBER
TO BE ABLE TO OFFER ANY COMMENTS
T BEFORE YOU DO I DO THINK THAT
THE AMENDMENTS YOU ARE WORKING
ON THESE AMENDMENTS. TO BE ABLE
TO STRIKE A COMPROMISE -- IN I I
DON'T WANT.
TO PUT WORDS INTO THE MADAM
PROTEINS -- MAYOR PRO TEM'S
MOUTH BUT I THINK THAT -- YOU
REALLY BEEN TRYING TO WORK ON
THIS BILL AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
ADVANCE WORK ON MANY OF THE
CONCERNS AND LIKE I SAY ALL THAT
MANY OF THE CONCERNS IN REGARDS
TO THAT DATA.
AS BEING REFERRED TO IT MAY NOT
GO FAR ENOUGH I GET IT -- BUT
WOULD LIKELY TO TURN OVER THE
SUMMER NUMBER AFTER THAT ISSUE.
I WANT TO THANK CAL CHAMBER IN
THE CALIFORNIA REAL TALE
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND GOING
NEUTRAL.
WHEN IT THANK THE MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF FRESNO WE BRAND? FOR
CHANGING POSITIONS AND
SUPPORTING THE BILL.
AB FOR EIGHTY FIVE WILL INCREASE
PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY AND SEEKS TO
GIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION. TO HOLD
AREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION
DISTRIBUTION COMPANIES THAT
RECEIVE TAXPAYER FUNDED
SUBSIDIES ACCOUNTABLE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOTH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
A SIMILAR I JUST ON THE ISSUE OF
THE AMENDMENTS I THINK THAT.
ON THOSE AMENDMENTS THOSE ARE
WHERE YOU WERE TRYING TO FOCUS
RIGHT ON NOT A BILLING DEAN SOME
OF THOSE AMENDMENTS IN REGARD TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS OR TO DANCE
AGAIN I'M NOT GONNA SAY THAT.
CAN SATISFY EVERYONE BUT I THINK
THAT WAS ONE OF THE POINTS AND
IN THE MIDST OF PLEASE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE.
TO COMMENT ON THAT SPECIFIC
QUESTION A PANTS THAT WAS THE
PURPOSE CORRECT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
A PLEASE MISTER VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
THESE DISTRIBUTION CENTERS ARE
GETTING TO BE QUITE INTERESTING
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE WATCHING
THE SYSTEMIC CHANGES IN OUR IN
OUR SOCIETY WITH THE TRANS AS
THEY THEY GENERATE SALES TAX.
AND THAT'S GENERATED BY INTERNET
SALES OVERSEEING THESE.
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS IN THE
CITIES WHERE THE WAREHOUSES
LOCATED.
A GENERATING A LOT OF SALES TAX
REVENUES -- BUT IT ISN'T GOING
TO PERHAPS THE CITY WHERE THE
PURCHASER AND SO -- THERE
THERE'S A LOT OF RETAIL ACTIVITY
IN ORANGE COUNTY BUT A
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES GETTING THE
SALES TAX.
AND I THINK I IT IT PUTS -- AN
AWKWARD COMPOUNDED INTO --
CITIES QUé AND COMPETING
AGAINST EACH OTHER TO GET THESE
WAREHOUSES SO I APPRECIATE THIS
BILL BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT --
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY ONE BY
GLAZER WAS A GOOD.
BILL AS WELL -- BUT IF WE'RE ALL
GONNA START COMPETING FOR SALES
TAX GENERATORS WE KIND OF GET
BLINDED. TO WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING AND I THINK ONCE THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES REALIZES THAT A
LOT OF THEIR MEMBERS ARE NOT
GETTING THE REVENUES THEY SHOULD
BE GETTING.
BECAUSE IT'S BEING.
CENTERED SOMEWHERE ELSE -- THEN
THEN IMAGES TO A BALLOT MEASURE.
AND THEN ALL THE CITIES THAT
GAVE SUBSIDIES ARE GONNA FIND
THEMSELVES.
LOSING THE SALES TAX REVENUE
THEREFORE PART COMING UP
NEGATIVE PAYING OUT MORE IN
SUBSIDIES THAN THEY'RE GETTING
AND SALES TAX BENEFITS I'M.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT SO I
APPRECIATE THE BILL I APPRECIATE
CERTAIN THE LABOR COMPONENT BUT
I'M I'M CONCERNED LONG TERM OR
WHAT HAPPENS TO THESE CITIES --
SHOULD.
THE WHOLE DYNAMIC CHANGED BY
DEVELOPING AGENCIES DISAPPEARED
AND AND YOU KNOW I CAN'T WE GIVE
I GAVE A LIST ALREADY HAVE ALL
THE THE FUNNY THING IS TO GO ON
A GOVERNMENT WHERE PEOPLE THINK
THEY'RE DOING A GREAT THING FOR
THEIR CITY.
BUT REALIZE AT THE END OF THE
DAY THAT THAT THEY HAD A YOU
KNOW SALESMAN IN TOWN WHO MADE
LOTS OF MONEY.
BACK TO THERE'S ONE GUY.
THAT WAS DISCLOSED AFTER WE
WE'VE FINISHED SB FIVE THIRTY
ONE THAT WAS GETTING A
PERCENTAGE OF THE SALES TAX FOR
ALL THIS CITIES THAT HE WAS ABLE.
TO CONVINCE THE VISION PUT
WAREHOUSES AND SO HE'S GOT THIS
INCOME STREAM THAT'S JUST.
IN THE MILLIONS JUST BECAUSE YOU
PUT IT IN THERE CONTRACTORS JUST
LIKE ALL MY GOODNESS THERE'S
THIS IS THIS IS SO WRONG.
SO -- MISTER -- WELL THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES DâN YOU MENTIONED
THAT THAT THIS WENT TOO FAR AND
I I I'M NOT SEEING IT I'M JUST
WONDERING IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND.
HELPING ME -- BECAUSE I I THINK
DISCLOSING TO YOUR RESIDENCE
THAT YOU'RE GONNA DO SOMETHING
THAT THE CITIZENS OF THAT CITY
YOU'RE GONNA UNDERWRITE A
PARTICULAR.
BUSINESS THEY SHOULD BE FULLY
AWARE OF OF WHAT IT IS IF
THEY'RE GIVING UP A HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR MORE OF THEIR TAXES
SO WHAT AM I MISSING. ZERO
NINETY THREE ENTITIES YOURSELF
PLEASE -- ALONG WITH YOUR TITLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR OGDEN CARRIED
WITH THE WE GET CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
ON ALL BACK TO SB FIVE THIRTY
ONE SENATOR YOU TALKED ABOUT
SALES TAXES I MEAN THE SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE DEAL SQUARELY WITH
THAT ISSUE OF SALES TAXE
INTERNET SALES.
AND ACTUALLY THE LEAGUE IS --
SUPPORTING AYE I GUESS SORT OF
SPONSORING FIVE THIRTY ONE
BECAUSE WE HAD A DAY INTENSIVE
POLICY DISCUSSION WITHIN THE
LEAGUE ABOUT THAT ISSUE AND
ESPECIALLY ABOUT SOME OF THE THE
THE THE GROWTH OF INTERNET AND
SOME OF THE ISSUES AND SO.
THAT'S WHY THAT BILL WOULD BE
AND THESE AGREEMENTS GOING
FORWARD WE SUPPORT THAT BUILDS
IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THIS ISSUE IF YOU TAKE THAT BILL
WOULD PUT THAT BILL ASIDE AND
SAY THAT GOES THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR SIGNS IT.
AND THE QUESTION IS WHERE WE
HAVE IN A WAREHOUSE SCHEMA WHERE
A CITY WITH A WAREHOUSE IN THIS
INSTANCE GO THROUGH ALL THE
HOOPS AND HURDLES THAT TAT THIS
BILL REQUIRES.
THIS BILL REQUIRES UNDER
EXISTING LAW IF YOU HAVE GIVEN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENTS IN OF YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A PUBLIC HEARING
AND THEN WHAT YOU GIVE THAT
INSTEAD OF YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
REPORT EVERY FIVE YEARS.
THIS BILL REQUIRES MUCH MORE
DETAIL RELATED TO A WAREHOUSE
AND ALSO REQUIRES ANNUAL PUBLIC
HEARINGS IN ANNUAL REPORTS
REPORTS TO GO BUSINESS AND OTHER
THINGS BUT NOT KNOW WHETHER --
ENTITY HOUSE TO DO IN FACT I
THINK IT PROBABLY GOES FURTHER
THAN THE STATE'S WHEN GOKU'S
GIVES OUT A CALIFORNIA COMPETES
CREDITS.
I DON'T THINK THERE HAVE AN
ANNUAL PUBLIC HEARINGS ON ON
THERE IT'S AND SO IT GOES TO
FOUR AND ENDED IT SINGLES OUT
THESE COMMUNITIES.
THE SALES TAX ISSUE WE WOULD
ARGUE HAS BEEN ADDRESSED IN
THERE -- FOR THE COMMUNITIES
OUGHT TO HAVE FLEXIBILITY TO THE
EXTENT THEY'RE USING THEIR OWN
REVENUES.
THE IN A AND I'LL JUST ADD
THOUGH JUST I THINK IT'S CLEAR.
THERE'S A DISTINCT DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN CENTER -- GLAZIERS BILL --
AS WELL AS THIS BILL THIS BILL
IS NOT JUST FOCUS ON SALES TAX
SALES TAXES FOCUS ON SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE WHICH IS GLAZERS BILL --
AND THIS BILL IS ON OTHER TYPES
OF SUBSIDIES SO IT'S THERE ARE
SOME DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THAT.
PERSON NEVER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO RESPOND AT ALL.
SO I AM THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT
REPRESENTS THE CITY OF MORENO
VALLEY AS WELL AS THE CITY OF
RIVERSIDE.
AND THE CITY OF PARIS -- AND
I'VE.
PRESENT THIS BILL BECAUSE I
AGREE.
WITH CENTER MORE LOCK THAT THE
CITIZENS OF A COMMUNITY SHOULD
VERY WELL KNOW WHERE THEIR TAX
DOLLARS ARE GOING.
I I I BELIEVE THAT.
ALSO  THINK CENTER MORE LIKE
SAID THAT MANY TIMES WAREHOUSES
COMING IN AND YOU COMMUNITY MAKE
PROMISES THAT ARE NOT.
A DELIVERED ON JOBS OR THE
REVENUE THAT THEY'RE THEY WOULD
CREATE OR THE KIND OF JOBS THAT
THEY CREATE.
AND FOR THAT REASON I THINK THIS
WEEK WE NEED THIS BILL I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE -- THE CITIZENS
DESERVE TO KNOW WHERE THEIR TAX
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THE NUMBER WE DO
HAVE A QUESTION BY -- MISTER
HURTS SENATOR -- FOLLOWING UP ON
A QUESTIONINGS BY SENATOR MORE
LOCKED.
AB THE SOLUTION. TO ALTERNATIVES
HERE.
IS WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
DANCING AROUND THE PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM IS BRADLEY BURNS.
WE'VE CREATED TAX STRUCTURE
CENTERS I MEAN GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER TRIED TO DEAL
WITH THIS AND WASN'T SUCCESSFUL --
BECAUSE WE INCENTIVIZE BIG BOX
RETAIL IN.
BIG CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES STEP
SMALL CITIES AROUND OF TO GET
THE BENEFIT OF THIS EXTRA PENNY
ON SALES TAX OR AUTO MALLS AND
THE LIKE.
IS IT A HOUSING WE TRIED TO DO
THAT AND COULD WIN THAT.
MAYBE WE SHOULD JUST EITHER A
ELIMINATE BRADLEY BURNS THAT
STOP STOPS THE PROBLEM IN THE IN
ITS TRACKS BECAUSE THERE'S
NOTHING TO OFFER WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE THAT MONEY OR BE DO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO BEFORE.
AND USE THAT BRADLEY BURNS MONEY
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH IS
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE HAVE A
HOUSING PROBLEM WE HAVE BECAUSE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WANT THE
MONEY.
AND THEY'D RATHER TAKE THE MONEY.
FOR TO PAY SUBSIDIZED Là
SERVICES THAT HOUSING WHICH
DOESN'T PROVIDE THE MONEY THAT
BIG BOX RETAILERS AUTO MALLS DO
SO MAYBE WE SHOULD JUST.
TO INDUCE A BILL AND JUST GET
READY BRADLEY BURNS AND AND
EVERYBODY'S ARGUMENTS WILL
CHANGE.
YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
ARGUING WHETHER WITH A REPORT
ABOUT THE MONEY THAT THEY'RE
TAKEN BUT THE PROBLEM IS.
NOW THERE'S BRADLEY BURNS
REVENUE STREAM WORKS AND IT'S
CREATED IT UNBELIEVABLE PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE NO I DON'T
THINK IT'S ACHIEVED THE
DELIVERABLES AND SOUGHT TO
ACHIEVE AND CREATED THIS
COMPETITIONS AMONG CITIES SO.
A CO AUTHOR THAT BILL YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE ONE LAST QUICK
COMMENT IF YOU I MEAN IF YOU SEE
YOURSELF MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CHASING AND SOLVE US AGAIN
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF MARINO
VALLEY.
AND WE UNDERSTAND SIR MORE LOCKS
CONCERNS AND AS NOTED ON ITEM
SIX IN THE ANALYSIS THE PRIOR
VETO MESSAGE SUGGEST THIS BILL
GOES TOO FAR.
CURRENT LAW HAS ABOUT FOURTEEN
PROVISIONS WERE YOU HAVE TO
REPORT UNDER FIFTY THREE ZERO
EIGHT THREE S. NUMBER JOBS
IMPACT YOU HAVE AN ANNUAL IMPACT
STUDY.
AND WHILE I KNOW SENATOR
HERTZBERG WHO KNOWS THIS I WOULD
ONLY SUGGEST THAT THE BRADLEY
BURNS IS THE ONLY UNIFORM --
REVENUE SOURCE COME TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS I WOULD PROBABLY
RATHER HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE DISPARITY PROPERTY TAX
SHARES AS A RESULT OF AB.
EIGHT AND THEN WE WOULD REALLY
HAVE A FIVE CONVERSATION BUT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT'S
PERHAPS FOR ANOTHER DAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
CENTERS FOR WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
TALK WITH YOU ABOUT SERVICE
TAXES SO -- HE'S GONNA GIVE
BACKS ON THAT AS WELL.
SO -- WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER
TO SENATOR ABOUT YOU CLEAR FOR
YOU THE AMENDMENTS.
THAT ARE BEING CONSIDERED.
THE LADY SIN I MAY THE MORNING.
A SERAPH LOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION THROUGH THE
AMENDMENTS -- WERE NEGOTIATED
WITH THE THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND THE RETAILER CITY OF FRESNO
THERE WAS AN ISSUE THAT THE VICE
MAYOR RAISED ABOUT PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION SOME OF THE
DISCLOSURES AROUND JOB QUALITY.
WE WORKED WITH IT THE CHAMBER
AND THE RETAILERS AND OTHER
OPPOSITION TO COME UP WITH.
MORE AGGREGATED SO RATHER THAN
ASKED FOR THE SPECIFIC WAGES FOR
SPECIFIC JOBS IT IS NOW WAGE
SCALES WHICH IS MORE AKIN TO
WHAT CALIFORNIA COMPETES ASK.
FOR BENEFITS AND WELL RATHER WE
HAD BEEN THE ORIGINAL BILL WHICH
WAS VETOED LAST YEAR SO THIS IS
A DIFFERENT BILL OF AND THAT THE
VETO MESSAGE THAT GOVERNOR BROWN
HAD -- THE HE WE ASK FOR THE
SPECIFIC VALUE OF THE BENEFIT
PACKAGE AND SO THIS IS THAT IS
LANGUAGE IS BEEN TAKEN OUT AND
IT'S MORE GENERALIZED WHETHER
BENEFITS ARE OFFERED.
AND ALSO ANOTHER PIECE WAS WE
WANTED TO MAKE IT CLEAR AT THE
REQUEST OF THE OPPOSITION THAT
THIS DOESN'T.
ABROGATE OR CHANGE ANY EXISTING
CONTRACTS IT IS ONLY GOING
FORWARD [inaudible]
OKAY SO [inaudible]
SO YOU'RE.
STILL REQUIRING THE WAGE.
GAIL ASIAN THE SKILL OKAY THAT'S
THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR ME YES AND
WHETHER IT'S TEMPORARY FOR ME I
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE MORE
IMPORTANT PARTS OF THE BILL --
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I HOPE THAT
WE DON'T WATER THAT DOWN --
BECAUSE I THINK AS OF FORMER ALL.
TEEN AGE -- WAREHOUSEMAN.
OF TWO GOT PAID VERY LITTLE.
WHEN I DID THE WORK AND -- HAD
SOME UNFORTUNATE EXPERIENCE
THERE OR I GOT.
A LAID OFF -- JUST ON I DIDN'T
HAVE ANY KNOWS THE JUST SAID
YOU'RE GONE.
THEY DID A KIND OF IN A FUNNY
WAY THE THE GOT THE BOSS SAID.
YOU KNOW -- THE THREE STOOGES
AND I SAID EVERYBODY.
THEY HAD A MEETING OF ALL THE
THE STOCK BOYS IN THE WAREHOUSE
WHEN HE SAID YEAH.
HE SAID OKAY I WANT YOU TO LINE AND SAY MOELLER AND CURLY SO
USE MOELLER AND CURLY.
HE SAID YOU KNOW I LIKE CURLY SO
YOU CURLY'S OR STAY IN.
THE MOST ON THE LARRY SH YOU'RE
GONE.
AND I HAPPEN TO BE A MODEL.
SO THAT'S HOW I GOT LAID OFF SO
I THINK I TAKE CARE OF YOU KNOW
WATCH IT WATCHING -- THE WAGES
AND HAVING GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES
[inaudible] FOR BUSINESSES AND
TO MAKE SURE.
THEY BENEFIT ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IT -- SPECIALLY THE WORKERS THAT
WORK IN THOSE FACILITIES -- IS
VERY IMPORTANT I APPRECIATE YOUR
BILL.
AND YOUR MOTIVATION FOR DOING IT.
OUR LEAD MOTION FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTRE BELL WE
HAVE A MOTION THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS SOME
MEMBER AND HAVE YOU DO A CLOSE
PLEASE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH IS A
MEMBER THANKS FOR ALL THE WORK
ON THIS WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE HEARING COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY.
AND THE CONVERSATION FROM ALL
SIDES DO PASTOR PREPARATIONS
MOTION DESIGN CHESTER ROLL CALL
PLEASE WARRIOR HI WHY I'M MORE
LOCK [inaudible]
BELL.
I HERTZBERG I RESPECT HER TOTAL.
FOR TITLE I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
THE MOBILE PHONE MARKET OKAY.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH SOME
NUMBER.
BUT IN GERMAN WE HAVE TO AUTHORS
IN THE HOUSE WE'RE GONNA START
WITH ITEM NUMBER FOR MISS A
MINUTE MR HIS AREA AND WANT TO
SEE.
THANK YOU TO THE SIM A MEMBER
FOR HIS PATIENTS TODAY.
WITHIN ARE GOING TO GO TO THE
MAYOR -- WE'RE GONNA GO.
TO MISTER GLORIA -- FIRST AND
FOREMOST THOUGH WE ARE GOING TO
BE HEARING FROM IS A MEMBER
NAZARIAN.
MISSION IS HEARING YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON YOUR BILL.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK A FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF THE
PRESENTATION THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND AGAIN SIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND TO APOLOGIZE
WELCOME TO COMMITTEE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND MY
PLEASURE.
AND I JUST WANT TO START OFF BY
SAYING THAT MY COLLEAGUE AND I
WERE DEBATING WHETHER OR NOT YOU
WERE MORE.
MISTER BELL YOU ARE MORE.
IN TUNE WITH MAYBE -- CURLY.
RATHER THAN MOPE BUT BUT BUT
THAT'S A DEBATE FOR ANOTHER TIME --
BUT WHEN YOU THINK THAT MEANS
THAT AVAIL.
AFTER THE SIDE BEFORE A VOTE ON
THIS -- I DAY.
DROPPING THE HAMMER WATCH OUT.
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
SIR.
THERE IS AFTER DIEM GOOD START
HERE HEY SEE THERE YOU GO.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
HER EIGHT WHAT WE NEEDED AT
SEVENTH INNING STRETCH FOR A
MINUTE RIGHT -- CRYSTAL I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING ME AND AND
GUIDING ME WITH THIS BILL THIS
IS A TECHNICAL BILL DEALING WITH
DEALING WITH THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS OF TWENTY YEARS FOR
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO COLLECT
ON AN OUTSTANDING.
WITH THAT I I WILL TURN IT OVER
TO JOSEPH BOILS WHO IS A TAX
ATTORNEY FROM LOS ANGELES AREA
WHO CAN SPEAK TO THE BILL A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO
LIMóN WELCOME TO COMMITTEE SIR
IF YOU DON'T MIND ENTITIES
YOURSELF FIRST CLASS
ORGANIZATION AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN SANDERS I'M
JOSEPH BOILS ON THE CALIFORNIA A
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT AND
ATTORNEY.
PRACTICING THE ART OF TAX LAW
LOS ANGELES -- FOR OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS THE INTERNAL
REVENUE CODE HAS PROVIDED A TEN
YEAR STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS ON
THE COLLECTION OF FEDERAL TAXES
CALIFORNIA DIDN'T HAVE A STATURE
LIMITATIONS ON THE COLLECTION OF
INCOME TAXES.
UNTIL TWO THOUSAND SIX IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED A TWENTY YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS -- WHICH I I TRIED
LEADERS THE LONGEST STRETCH
LIMITATIONS OF IN THE STATE THE
COUNTRY TWICE THE FEDERAL LAW.
BUT THE MECHANICS OF THE FEDERAL
STATE STATUTEARE DIFFERENT
UNDER THE FEDERAL STATUTE.
THERE'S A TEN YEAR STATUTE
LIMITATIONS ON EACH AND EVERY
ASSESSMENT OF TAX.
UNDER CALIFORNIA'S LAW THERE'S A
TWENTY YEAR STATURE LIMITATIONS
ON EACH TAX YEAR.
IF THERE ARE MULTIPLE
ASSESSMENTS OF TAX WITHIN ONE
TAX YEAR THE TWENTY YEAR CLOCK
BEGINS TO RUN FROM THE LAST
ASSESSED TAX.
SO THOSE WILL NOT LOOK DOES THE
MECHANICS.
BUT THERE'S A FLAW IN IN THE
MECHANICS AND THAT.
UP THE THE THE STATUTE CURRENTLY
DEFIANCE A TAX LIABILITY TO
INCLUDE INTEREST PENALTIES AND
FEES AND COSTS.
WELL.
INTEREST ACCRUES DAILY SO IF IF
THE TWENTY YEAR CLOCK BEGINS TO
RUN FROM THE LAST ASSESSED
AMOUNT.
INTEREST ACCRUES DAILY THE
TWENTY YEAR CLOCK BEGINS EVERY
DAY.
SIMILARLY THE THE IT THE FTV
ROUTINELY CHARGES FEES AND COSTS
FOR COLLECTION THERE'S A
EIGHTEEN DOLLAR LEAN FEE THERE'S
A THIRTY DOLLAR OR FIFTY DOLLAR --
FEE ON INSTALLMENT AGREEMENTS
ALL OF THOSE FEES AND COSTS
RESTART THE TWENTY YEAR STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS. FOR THE TWENTY
OR STATURE WOULD LIMITATION
BECOMES ILLUSORY.
THIS BILL IS THE TECHNICAL
CORRECTION THAT TO FIGHT THE
THAT REDEFINES THE AMOUNTS THAT
RESTART THE STATUTE AS TAX ONLY.
SO IF THERE'S IF THERE'S A NEW
ASSESSMENT OF TAX THE TWENTY
YEAR CLOCK BEGINS TO RUN AGAIN.
INTEREST FEES COST THOSE ITEMS
WILL NO LONGER RESTART THE
TWENTY YEAR CLOCK THE TECHNICAL
CORRECTION AND THAT'S THAT'S HOW
IT WORKS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU DID THE D. FIVE
VERY HELPFUL.
GREATLY APPRECIATE HER THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING COMMITTEE WITH
NECESSARY.
GOOD MORNING LOOKING FOR SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISSY TALKED WITH
NELSON MARKS WERE HERE BEHALF OF
THAT CALIFORNIA'S DECIDED FOR
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR
BEING HERE WOULD LIKE TO BE AT
OFFER ANYONE ELSE.
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL WE ARE GOING TO TURN
OVER TO THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
OPPOSITION LAST CALL.
ME BACK TO COMMITTEE TURN OVER
THE PAST YEAR.
ABOUT SEVENTEEN QUESTIONS MISTER
A HOT DAY I'M OF THE BILL ALL
RIGHT THE GUY THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION.
THE MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD LIKE THERE
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
BY COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME.
CURRENCY NONE WERE TURNED OVER
TO SOME MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO
OFFER CLOSING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR JUST VERY SIMILAR
TO THE WAY WE CONDUCT OURSELVES
IN OUR DISTRICT THIS WAS AN
ISSUE THAT CAME UP THROUGH
SEVERAL DIFFERENT CALLS.
A MONTH FROM MY CONSTITUENTS WE
WE LOOKED INTO IT WE REALIZE
THAT THERE'S A BIT OF A LOOPHOLE
THAT WE CAN HELP -- AMELIORATE
AND THAT'S HOW THIS BILL CAME
ABOUT SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THE SHOPS A MEMBER THANK
YOU SO MUCH AGAIN DO PASSED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS THAT'S OUR
MOTION THE FLOOR MISS LANE
CHESTER ROLL CALL PLEASE
HERTZBERG.
FIRST REGARD HER CONDO YOUR
TOTAL AYE NIELSEN.
YES AND I WIENER. SIXTEEN OKAY
THAT WE HAVE A SIX YEAR VOTE WE
CAN KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN AND A
HOUSE IN A WINNER THAT ADAM
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
THAT JOB.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TURN IT OVER.
TO A SIMILAR GLORIA THIS IS AB.
FOR TWENTY THREE WE WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU THIS A
MEMBER.
FOR WORKING WITH US.
BUT HE IS TAKING ON A BIG ISSUE.
IN A CERTAIN FROM THE GROUND UP
ON THIS.
AS FAR AS A NEW COMPOSITION OF
THE COMMISSION.
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP -- IN
WORKING WITH US THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I WANT
TO TAKE YOUR STAFF AS WELL FOR
WORKING WITH US -- TO MAKE AG
AXLE IMPROVEMENTS TO THIS BILL I
WANT TO SAY ON THE RECORD I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THOSE OF WILL BE
TAKEN AND SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE.
US VERY QUICKLY EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY THREE WAS STRUCTURE
STANDING WAS AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT BOARD AND THEN
DIRECTS THEM TO INCREASE THEIR
PROGRAM TRANSPARENCY.
THE BILL WILL BE RECONSTITUTED
TO INCLUDE THAT REPRESENTATION
FROM ADDITIONAL SAN DIEGO CITIES
AS WELL AS OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU AIDS A CITY WAS A PCD
BOARD REPRESENTS OVER THREE
MILLION PEOPLE ACROSS EIGHTEEN
CITIES HOWEVER UNLIKE OTHER
LARGE URBAN -- AIR DISTRICTS
THAT OVERSEE A SINGLE COUNTY THE
COMPOSITION OF THE A PC BOARD
CURRENTLY SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDES
LOCAL CITIES FROM HAVING A SEAT
ON THE BOARD.
IS THAT THE BOARD IS MADE UP
ENTIRELY OF BOARD MEMBERS OF THE
CITY OF COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE AT THE
PERSPECTIVES AND INSIGHTS OF
OTHER LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
SOURCES.
THE CIVIC WE CITIES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THESE EXPERIENCES I
THINK WITHIN FOUR BETTER
DECISION MAKING EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY THREE WOULD ALSO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY REQUIRING THE BOARD
TO AMONG OTHER THINGS CREATE A
SEPARATE WEBSITE.
APPLY FOR STATEWIDE GRANTS AND
FEDERAL INCENTIVE PROGRAMS --
EVALUATE THE PUBLIC COMPLAIN
COMMENT PROCESS AND DEVELOP A
PLAN FOR COMPREHENSIVE AIR
MONITORING A BEFORE TWENTY THREE
IS SUPPORTED BY DIVERSE
COALITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
DAN TALKED FOR IN WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH COALITION AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES.
BOARD THANK YOU MISTER GLORY DAY
AND WELCOME TO COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF TWO MINUTES WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE THANK YOU
SO MUCH -- CHAIRMAN REQUIRE AND
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA SAID I
AM WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
COALITION AND SERVICE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE ERRORS
RESOURCES BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH POLLUTION
IS SPONSORING THIS BILL --
BECAUSE WE ARE -- TIRED OF
HAVING TO HEALTH AND ON OUR MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES CONTINUE
UNABATED -- AND WE BELIEVE THAT
A CHANGE IN THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT BOARD -- REALLY
WILL RESOLVE THE PROBLEM AND IT
REALLY DEMONSTRATES THE NEED FOR
ACTION.
THE NEED FOR CHANGE IN
REPRESENTATION IS VERY CLEAR THE
AIR AIR POLLUTION CONTROL BOARD
OF SAN DIEGO IS AN ANOMALY AMONG
THE LARGE DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
IT'S THE PRODUCT OF A TWENTY
FIVE YEAR OLD PROVISIONS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED. TO EXAM
SAN DIEGO COUNTY FROM HAVING A
DIVERSE AND REPRESENTATIVE BOARD
WE BELIEVE THAT THE NEED FOR
DIRECT ACTION IS CLEAR -- AND
THAT THE NEED FOR TRANSPARENCY
IS VERY VERY EVIDENT WE HAVE
EXAMPLES SUCH AS THE FACT THAT
THE BOARD MINUTES ARE BURIED
WITHIN THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS -- MINUTES AND
THEY'RE NOT ACCESSIBLE TO THE
PUBLIC -- ONLINE REQUEST FOR
DATA GOAL -- ON RESPONDED -- TO
AFTER MULTIPLE REQUESTS -- AND
MONITORING DATA FROM THE
EXISTING MONITORS TAKES YEARS TO
BE PROCESS WE HAVE JUST RECEIVED
TWENTY SIXTEEN DATA.
OTHER LARGE DISTRICTS HAVE
ROBUST PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
PROCESS SEES AND ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH AUTHENTIC
PARTICIPATION FROM IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES WE AGREE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOUR COMMITTEE
HAS PROVIDED AND WE APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE.
TO TO DEVELOP THOSE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU RECALL
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA
ASK FOR THOSE WHO ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD THIS TIME.
WE HAVE A SQUISHY.
ALL RIGHT COME ON FOR SIR
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
I DOING TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I PREFER --
TWEENER BUT BORDERS WIENER
SQUISHY -- JONATHAN CLAIM TO
HAVE THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO --
ALSO OFFICE AND WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA THE
SPONSORS AND STAFF AND PUT IN
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS.
WITH THE MOST RECENT SETTLEMENT
THAT WILL BE GOING TO THE BILL --
ESPECIALLY RELATED TO THE FEE
ISSUE WHICH WAS OUR REMAINING
OUTSTANDING ISSUE -- THAT THAT
ADDRESSES ALL OF OUR CONCERNS OF
THE PROPOSAL SO.
AND WE GREATLY APPRECIATE -- THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS EFFORTS IN
WORKING WITH US NOT LOOK I I
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT I THINK THIS
IS -- IN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN ALL
SIDES -- WANTING TO ADDRESS
WANNA TAKE LONGER TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE COUNTY -- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK THE ALL.
AND FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND LOOK
FORTY HERE AND SOME ADDITIONAL
FEEDBACK AS WELL SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANKS FOR BEING HERE AND
HAVE YOU HANG.
THESE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF THAT
WORKS FOR YOU WOULD LIKE ME TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE WHO HAS
CONCERNS OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORTH
THIS TIME.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION.
THIS IS GONNA BE LAST CALL WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT.
EVER GO HEY DOING.
WE HAVE SOME OTHER ACCOUNTS
CHAMBER WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WHILE THE
AUTHOR TO ADDRESS IN CONCERT
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE
ACTIVITIES REQUIRED BY THE BILL
OF THE DISTRICT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE [inaudible]
LAST CALL.
ALL RIGHT HERE AND SEE NO ONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE SEE
IF ANY QUESTIONS CONVERSATION
PLEASE MR VICE CHAIR.
SURE I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION IS
PLEASE -- IN IN THE BRIEFING
MATERIAL IT.
UNDER LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS THE
SECOND SENTENCE THAT STATE LAW
SPELLS OUT THE MEMBERSHIP.
OF THESE LOCAL AIR DISTRICT'S
GOVERNING BOARDS BUT THERE ARE
MANY VARIATIONS AND I'M JUST
CURIOUS YOU KNOW DOESN'T GIVE
LIKE A CODE CITATION OF WHERE TO
LOOK.
BUT WHAT IS WHAT IS THE OF A
BOARD SUPPOSED TO BE COMPRISED
OF YOU KNOW.
AS WE M. DUG INTO THIS ISSUE --
THERE IS NO MAGIC FORMULA -- BUT
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO BE TO GET YOU
THE CODE SECTION -- BUT YEAH
IT'S IT'S THE CODE SECTIONS NOT
BUT IF YOU GO TO PAGE TWO OF SIX
FIRST PARAGRAPH.
OF THE TWENTY ONE SINGLECOUNTY
DISTRICT SEVEN HAVE BOARDS WITH
CITY REPRESENTATION AND FOURTEEN
AND BOARDS WITH ONLY COUNTY
SUPERVISORS.
SO HERE'S WHERE WE CAME AND I'M
GONNA LOOK TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ON THIS ISSE AND FEEL
FREE.
NOW IT'S IT'S IT'S OPEN IN SO --
AND I'M GONNA HAVE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIME IN ON THIS AS WELL.
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS WAS DIVERSE
DIVERSE IN REGARDS TO ITS
AIR RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD THE
REASON WHY WE DO THAT.
IS BECAUSE WE SHOULD ALWAYS HAVE
THE INDIVIDUAL.
WHO IS AN EXPERT IN THAT ISSUE
OF AIR QUALITY ON BOTH BOARDS?
SINCE SAN DIEGO ALSO HAS A SEAT
ON THE STATE BOARD. ONE SAN
DIEGO CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
BECAUSE OF POPULATION. FIVE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS. ONE FROM EACH
OF THE FIVE COUNTY BOARD
DISTRICTS.
THAT WOULD THEN BE APPOINTED BY
THE CITY SELECTION COMMITTEE.
THE THREE PUBLIC BOARD MEMBERS
WOULD BE APPOINTED -- IT COULD
BE THROUGH AN AD HOC OF THE
COMMITTEE OR THE COMMITTEE OF
THE WHOLE OF THAT NEW BOARD.
SO AGAIN TRYING TO BE ABLE TO
GET AROUND THE COUNTY TO BRING A
VARIETY OF VOICES IN.
AND THEN ALSO ENSURING THAT THE
PUBLIC ALSO HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE.
THERE IS NO FORMAL DEFINITION --
AND WE WE THINK WE'VE HIT THE
SWEET SPOT.
NOT SURE EVERYONE IS GOING.
TO BE HAPPY AS WITH ANY ISSUE
PATTERN OF THIS IN THE NUMBER TO
SEE WHAT I MISSED YOU -- COVERED
PRETTY WELL MISS JANET INTO FOR
THE VICE CHAIR IF I CAN AIDS
REFER TO MY WITNESS WHO I THINK
CAN PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE DETAIL
BUT YOU MIGHT BE LOOKING.
FOR I CAN'T WRITE THE CODE
SECTION SORRY I DON'T HAVE IT IN
FRONT OF ME BUT I DO -- KNOW
THAT EACH OF THE LARGE DISTRICTS
HAS A DIFFERENT COMPOSITION BUT
THEY GENERALLY HAVE THE SAME
IDEA OF HAVING PUBLIC MEMBERS
MEMBERS FROM EACH OF THE CITIES
OF OR THE REGION'S WITHIN A
COUNTY AND EACH ONE IS COMPRISED
DIFFERENTLY SOME HAVE APPOINTEES
FROM.
THE GOVERNOR FROM ARM TO THE US
SENATE PRETENDING FROM THE
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER THERE'S
DIFFERENT COMPOSITIONS FOR EACH
ONE OF THE LARGE DISTRICTS BUT
ALL OF THEM ARE DIVERSE AND HAVE
A HAVE A DIFFERENT KIND OF
COMPOSITION SO THIS ONE IS IN
KEEPING WITH -- WITH THOSE OF
DISTRICTS AS WELL IF YOU JUST TO
PUT IT SUCCINCTLY WE ARE THE
SECOND LARGEST A REGION IN THE
STATE AND YET WE OPERATE
CURRENTLY AS ONE OF THE SMALL
COUNTIES AND THAT'S NOT WORKING
ANY LONGER.
NO NO AND I SEE THAT AND I I
HAVE THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
RESOURCE.
ALL ABOARD AN INTENSE I'M
LOOKING AT AGAIN THE NO BETTER
NO WORSE PHILOSOPHY OF IF WE'RE
GONNA FIX SAN DIEGO WHY DON'T WE
SET AT A TEMPLATE FOR EVERYBODY.
SO WE'RE ALL FOLLOWING THE SAME.
FORMAT AND THAT'S SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION WOULD BE WHY JUST THIS
DISTRICT IN WHY NOT.
YOU KNOW IT'S GIVE THE UNIFORM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO WE'RE
ALL PLAYING ON THE SAME.
FIELD.
BUT THE WORST IDEA I'VE EVER
HEARD OUT MILEY THAT ANOTHER GUY --
GALLAGHER GUY TO TAKE ON I'M
JUST TRYING TO CARE TAKE CARE OF
ALL RIGHT NOW.
THAT AGAIN AND TRY TO TAKE CARE
OF MY DISTRICT RIGHT NOW YEAH I
MEAN I I GET THE POINT THAT
YOU'RE MAKING -- I THINK THIS
PUBLIC FOR SOME ABOVE MY PAY
GRADE.
WELL THEY WERE GONNA HAVE IKE
THIRTY OTHER DISTRICTS COME IN
OVERTIME RIGHT DO THE SAME THING
SO I'M JUST TRYING.
TO LOOK AT IT FROM AN OFFICIAL
STANDPOINT IF THIS IS A GREAT
IDEA THAN IT SHOULD BE A GREAT
IDEA FOR EVERYBODY.
YOU SHOULD BE COMMENDED FOR THAT.
WE SHOULD WE SHOULD JUST
RESOLVING ALL ACROSS WORK THERE
WAS JUST MIKE MIKE WEIR THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU MISTER.
I THINK WE MAY HAVE A BILL IDEA
IN THE MAKING.
SO A DOCTOR AMOUNTS.
RIGHT NOW ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIR.
WOULD LIKE ME TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE WE ALSO
WOULD WELCOME A MOTION ON THIS
ISSUE.
WE HAVE A MOTION A MOTION BY
CENTER TACO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN FRONT
OF US TODAY WILL BE TAKING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE.
RICHARD OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO BE ABLE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
YOUR HELP I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION COUNTY SAN DIEGO --
AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS BACK ON
FOR GAME IS TO A POINT WHERE I
THINK AS YOU SAID WE HAD A SWEET
SPOT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL AGAIN IS A MEMBER THANK
YOU FOR THE CONVERSATION
COMMITTEE THANK YOU TO THE
COUNTY FOR BEING HERE MISSING
CHESTER WE CAN GO WITH A ROLL
CALL VOTE PLEASE.
WIRED HIGH WIRE I'M MORE LOCK.
BELL.
I HERTZBERG.
FIRST REGARD HER CONDO
[inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER. FOR THANK YOU HAVE A
CELL NUMBER A VERY GRATEFUL TO
ALWAYS WORK WITH YOU EMERGENCY
THE SIMILAR BACK HERE IN THE
NEXT WEEK OR TWO SOME GOOD TAX
SIR AL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ALL.
THANK YOU DAN.
WE HAD.
SOME NUMBER CALL ROBERT LOOKS
LIKE HE MAY HAVE LEFT THE WE'RE
GONNA AT WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT MR
OBERNOLTE IS HERE WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
THIS IS AB.
SIX TEN AB SIXTEEN IN REGARD TO
LOCAL BOND MEASURES.
BEFORE MR OBERNOLTE GETS GOING I
WANNA.
PERSON RECOGNIZED FOR ALL THIS
WORK ON A SEPARATE ISSUE AND
THAT'S THE ISSUE OF THE BUDGET --
HE'S BEEN LIVING THE DREAM OVER
THE PAST MANY MONTHS -- ALONG
WITH MISTER MOORE LOCK -- EACH
YOUR VICE CHAIRS IN THE
RESPECTIVE HOUSES AND JUST WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THIS A MEMBER FOR ALL
THIS WORK. TO MEMBER THE FLOOR
IS YOURS AND ITEM SEVEN A. B.
SIXTEEN WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CURRENT STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT
WHEN A BOND IS APPROVED BY
VOTERS.
THAT THE ABOUT BALLOT --
STATEMENT NEXT TO THE BOX WE
CHECK YES OR NO TO VOTE INCLUDES
AN ESTIMATE OF THE AMOUNT OF
PROPERTY TAX INCREASE THAT WILL
BE REQUIRED TO SERVICE THAT BOND.
CURRENTLY STATE LAW REQUIRES
THAT TO BE EXPRESSED IN TERMS OF
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS OF DOLLARS
PER HUNDRED DOLLARS OF ASSESSED
VALUE.
THIS BILL AB SIX TEN WOULD
SIMPLY CHANGE THAT TO DOLLARS
POORER THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
ASSESSED VALUE.
THIS IS -- AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
DECREASING VOTER CONFUSION AND
HELPING PEOPLE TO DO THE MATH
BECAUSE THE AVERAGE HOUSE IN
CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY WORTH
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO -- THIS BILLABLE
WHERE HAS OPTED OPPOSITION AND
WHAT ADDRESS A COUPLE OF THE
POINTS IN THE OPPOSITION LETTERS
THAT I'M SURE YOU'VE READ.
FIRST OF ALL -- THERE HAVE BEEN
CLAIMS MADE THAT THIS ACTUALLY
INCREASES VOTER CONFUSION OF
ALTHOUGH NO ONE HAS TOLD ME
EXACTLY WHY THEY FEEL THIS WAY
BUT LET ME TELL YOU A SIMPLE
EXAMPLE WHY I BELIEVE THAT THIS
ACTUALLY DECREASES VOTER
CONFUSION.
SO A TYPICAL BY BOB BALLOT
MEASURE -- FOR APPROVAL OF NEW
BOND MIGHT SAY THAT THIS BOND
WILL INCREASE TAXES BY EIGHT
CENTS PER HUNDRED DOLLARS OF
ASSESSED VALUE SO PRETEND THAT
YOU HAVE A HOUSE THAT'S WORTH.
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS HOW WOULD YOU DO THE
MATH TO FIGURE OUT WHAT YOUR TAX
INCREASE WOULD BE.
MAKING YOU THINK OF THE STEPS
THAT YOU WOULD TAKE I'LL TELL
YOU THE MAJORITY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS COULD NOT COME UP
WITH THOSE STEPS.
BUT IF WE JUST SIMPLY EXPRESSED
IT IN DOLLARS PER HUNDRED
DOLLARS EXCESS VALUE THAT WOULD
BE EIGHTY CENTS PER HUNDRED
DOLLARS IT'S CLEAR TO PEOPLE IF
THEY'RE FOUR HOUSES WORTH.
BORDER TO TWENTY THOUSAND THEY
WOULD JUST MULTIPLY BY FORD AND
TWENTY ANOTHER.
CONCERN HAS BEEN RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION IS THAT AND SOMETIMES
IT'S RAISED EXPLICITLY AND
SOMETIMES A SAID IMPLICITLY BUT
ANOTHER CONCERN IS THAT THIS
WILL MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT. TO
GET BONDS APPROVED BY VOTERS
BECAUSE THE AMOUNT OF THE TAX
INCREASE WILL LOOK BIGGER IF WE
MULTIPLY BY TEN EXPRESS IT PER
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND PERCENT OF
PER HUNDRED DOLLARS.
HOWEVER I'D LIKE GIVEN THE
SERGEANTS OF MATERIALS TO PASS
AROUND TO YOU THAT SAYS THAT
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY FALSE THERE'S
A SERIES OF ARTICLES IN THERE
WITH CITATIONS.
THE ACADEMIC LITERATURE THAT
SHOW THAT WHEN VOTERS ARE
CONFUSED ABOUT AN ISSUE
INCLUDING HOW MUCH THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO PAY THEY'RE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO VOTE NO.
THE TO VOTE YES AND SO I BELIEVE
THAT BY DECREASING VOTER
CONFUSION AND MAKING IT MORE
CLEAR WHAT'S SOMETHING WILL COST
THEM THEY WILL ACTUALLY BE MORE
LIKELY TO APPROVE IT.
THEN TO DISAPPROVE IT.
SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
SENT OVER THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
LOOKING FOR THOSE FOR IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
LAST CALL.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ANYONE WHO'S IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR THIS
TIME.
ROOM CHECKED RESPECT FROM THEIR
SPERM OR WOULD LIKE TO COME FOR
WHATEVER WORKS FOR YOU PLEASE
WELCOME.
HIS EGO WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT BOTH
YOUR HERE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST AN
ORGANIZATION YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH.
THE MORNING REBEKAH CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION PRODUCT
WITH SCHOOL HOUSING WE ARE
OPPOSED.
TO EIGHTY SIX TEN AM WE BELIEVE
THAT THE CHANGE IS UNNECESSARY
AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT IT COULD
INCREASE VOTER CONFUSION OF THE
QUESTION FOR ME IS REALLY WHAT
PROBLEM ARE WE TRYING TO SOLVE
AND WHAT IMPROVEMENT WITH THIS
REALLY MAKE.
WE DO APPRECIATE TRANSPARENCY IN
COMMUNICATING VERY CLEARLY WITH
VOTERS THE IMPACT THAT A MEASURE
MAY HAVE ON THEM THE TAX RATE
STATEMENT IN THE VOTER
INFORMATION GUIDE IS A GREAT
PLACE TO DO THIS IT CONTAINS A
LOT OF VERY.
IMPORTANT INFORMATION.
IF AB SIX TENNIS PASSED IT WILL
BE THE ONLY PLACE THAT I KNOW OF
IN THE LAW WHERE WE ARE
EXPRESSING -- PROPERTY VALUES
PER ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS RATHER
THAN ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
ASSESSED VALUATION VOTERS ARE
REQUIRED O DO BASIC MATH IN
EITHER CALCULATION AND TO
PRECISELY DETERMINE THE
ESTIMATED TAX INCREASE FOR THEIR
PARTICULAR PROPERTY VALUE.
UP BECAUSE OF THIS WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT A THOUSAND DOLLARS
ACTUALLY IMPROVES THE
CALCULATION AND ANYWAY IT'S THE
EXACT SAME MATH PROBLEM -- YOU
KNOW FIVE CENTS PER ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS UNDER CURRENT LAW OR
FIFTY CENTS PER THOUSAND DOLLARS
UNDER AB SIX TEN IT'S THE SAME
MOUTH.
ADDITIONALLY WE DO FEAR THAT
MAKING THIS CHANGE IN THE TAX
RATE STATEMENT COULD SET A
PRECEDENT AND PROP FUTURE
CHANGES ON THE BALLOT LABEL.
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES THAT
SCHOOLS AND OTHER LOCAL AGENCIES
ARE FACING IN IMPLEMENTING OTHER
RECENT ELECTIONS CODE CHANGES WE
DO FEAR THAT SIX TEN COULD
CREATE A SLIPPERY SLOPE.
AN EVEN MORE CHALLENGES IN
COMMUNICATING EFFECTIVELY WITH
OUR VOTERS ARE FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE POST THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH GRATEFUL.
GOOD MORNING FOR THIS LETTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTY BAMA
THE OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS I HAD
A GOOD SENSE THE PREVIOUS
WITNESS WOULD COVER ALL OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
THE SEEMS TO INSERT VOTER
CONFUSION TO IS A TACTIC
TAXPAYERS MONEY TO CREATE A
DIFFERENT STANDARD FOR LOCAL
BALLOT MEASURES AND FOR TRYING
TO DO ADVOCACY MATH HERE WE
SHOULD JUST SAY IT -- SO WEIRD
OPPOSITION THIS BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU BOTH OF YOU
WE'RE GONNA HAVE -- ONE OF YOU
HANGING LIKE WE TYPICALLY DO --
DURING COMMITTEE -- IN CASES
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE'RE NOW
GOING TO OPEN UP ANYONE ELSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR THIS
TIME.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA TURN IT
BACK.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS
ABOUT WHAT WHAT HAS SAID AND
WILL OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO AGAIN --
IT'S EASY TO SAY THAT THIS
INCREASES VOTER CONFUSION NO ONE
HAS SAID WHY THEY FEEL THIS
INCREASES VOTER CONFUSION I
THINK THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
IT DECREASES VOTER CONFUSION.
THE ASSERTION WAS MADE THAT IS
THE SAME MATH PROBLEM WELL IT'S
ACTUALLY NOT YOU HAVE TO KNOW
WHAT NUMBERS TO PUSH ON THE
CALCULATOR IF YOU USING ONE AND
IF YOU CAN'T CONCEPTUALIZE.
WHAT NUMBERS TO PUSH THEN YOU
DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS THAT YOU
NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THIS
WOULD COST YOU?
BUT EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY EVEN
IF WE ACCEPT THE FACT THAT IT'S
THE SAME MATH PROBLEM IN MY
BUSINESS.
WE HAVE.
A LOT OF DATA THAT -- THE THE
DETERMINES TO THAT WHEN WE HAVE
A NEW CUSTOMER AND WE'RE TRYING
TO CONVINCE THAT CUSTOMER TO BUY
OUR PRODUCTS EVERY STEP THAT WE
REQUIRE THAT CUSTOMER TO TAKE
MAKES IT LESS LIKELY THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO PURCHASE.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE SAME IS
TRUE IN A SITUATION LIKE THIS
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW MUCH OF BOND ISSUE IS GOING
TO COST YOU SO EVEN IF?
A VOTER IN BOTH CASES KNEW
EXACTLY WHAT TO DO THEY WOULD
HAVE TO PUSH AN EXTRA BUTTON ON
THE CALCULATOR TO MAKETHE
CALCULATION UNDER THE CURRENT
STAY LOCKED.
DOWN UNDER THE PROPOSED CHANGES
MADE BY A. B..
SIX TEN AND ABOUT WHAT LEGAL
LASTLY JUST ONE LET ME JUST SAY
THAT -- THE MORE TRANSPARENCY
THAT WE HAVE WITH VOTERS I THINK --
THE BETTER -- PROBABLY ONE MORE
SEARCH THAT WAS MADE WAS THE THE
POINT THAT CURRENT STATE LAW
USUALLY EXPRESSES VALUATIONS IN
TERMS OF DOLLARS PER HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND THAT S TRUE THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF PLACES AND STATE
LAW THAT THAT'S TRUE.
BUT THAT I NOT A PUBLIC FACING
PORTION OF THE STATE LAW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE REQUIRED
BALLOT LANGUAGE AND SO IT'S
REALLY APPLES AND ORANGES TO SAY.
THAT -- WELL YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
THE CONVENTION IS IN STATE LAW
AND WHAT WE PUT ON THE BALLOT
WE'RE TRYING TO BE AS
TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE SO I
HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTIONS
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT ANYONE ELSE MIGHT HAVE.
YOU SO MUCH TO SOMEONE WE'D LIKE
TO GET OPEN UP FOR THE COMMITTEE
MISTER VICE CHAIR PLEASE
[inaudible]
SHARE -- I I ALWAYS THOUGHT IT
WAS IN THOUSANDS -- ALREADY FIVE
KIND OF FASCINATED BY THE BILL
THAT THAT IT THAT WERE SAYING
IT'S AN HUNDREDS -- BECAUSE MOST
OF THE REPORTS THAT WE PUT OUT
IS A GOVERNMENT -- WILL WILL
REFLECT THAT IS IS IN THOUSANDS
OF WILL DROP THREE THREE DIGITS --
BUT IOWA WHEN I WHEN I WAS
TREASURER I WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ASSISTING THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITH THEIR BOND MEASURES.
AND SO YOU GET TO LEARN SOME OF
THE DIRTY LITTLE SECRETS AND I'M
SORRY SENATOR HERTZBERG ISN'T
HERE BUT IDEAS FOR BILLS YOU
KNOW -- WHAT WHAT USUALLY HAPPEN
IS BECAUSE THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
HAD TO DO A BALLOT MEASURE THEY
COULDN'T SPEND THEIR OWN MONEY
TO ADD TO IT ANALYZE HOW TO PUT
THIS TOGETHER?
THE BOND TOGETHER SO USUALLY --
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN MY COUNTY --
A BOND UNDERWRITER WOULD COME IN
AND AND THEY WOULD PAY FOR THE
POLLING AND THEY WOULD PAY FOR
ALL THE PRELIMINARY WORK AND
THEY WOULD THE AT THE POLLING
WOULD BE LIKE THIS -- DO YOU
THINK YOU COULD PAY TEN DOLLARS
PER.
THOUSAND OR TWENTY DOLLARS PER
THOUSAND OR THIRTY DOLLARS PER.
THOUSAND AND THEN THEY COME BACK
TO THE POLL RESULTS AND IT WOULD
SAY YOU KNOW THE MAGIC NUMBERS
EIGHTEEN DOLLARS PER THOUSAND SO
THEN THEY LOOK AT THAT SAYS
VALUE.
IN THE IN THE IN THE DISTRICT
IMAGE OKAY WE CAN DO A BOND
BASED ON EIGHTEEN TIMES THE
THOUSAND IN AND THEN THEY WOULD
COME UP WITH THE BOND AMOUNT
THAT THEY WOULD PUT ON THE
BALLOT.
BY THAT THAT POLLING DATA NOT BY
WHAT THEY NEEDED TO DO TO REPAIR
SCHOOLS ARE AT GYMS OR BUILD
TOOLS IT WAS BASED ON THIS
POLLING.
NUMBER.
AND I JUST THOUGHT OH MY
GOODNESS THE SIZING ISN'T EVEN.
BASED ON REAL HARD HARD DATA SO.
THEN THEN THE BOND WOULD PASS
AND THEN WHO GOT THE BUSINESS
BUT THE THE FIRM THAT DID ALL
THE POLLING ALL THE SO IT'S KIND
OF LIKE THIS COTTAGE INDUSTRY
THAT JUST KIND OF BLEW MY MIND.
AND I I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
EVEN.
WHERE WE SHOULD BE BUT I I THINK
THE IDEA OF STAYING UNIFORM WITH
THOUSANDS MAKES MUCH MORE SENSE
THAN HUNDREDS OR I THINK THE
BILL SHOULD EVEN DO BOTH WE
SHOULD PROVIDED?
AS A COST PER HUNDREDS AT A COST
PER THOUSAND SO WE CAN ASSIST
VOTERS WHEN THEY'RE MAKING THE
MAP DECISIONS IN.
THE POLLING PLACE OPEN BOTH SO
I'LL ALLAH A MOVE THE BILL BE
STRUCTURE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CENTER MORE LOCK WOULD LIKE ME
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS I WILL HAVE
SOME VERY BRIEF ITEMS COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS.
UP WHAT I TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU THIS SUMMER FOR ALL
THIS WORK -- ON THIS ISSUE.
AND IN THE SUMMER AND I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS -- IN MY
ONLY WORDS WILL BE THIS IS AT
NUMBER ONE I HAVE NOT HEARD.
FROM VOTERS ON THE NORTH COAST
OR THE NORTH BAY AREA ABOUT
CONFUSION RELATED TO SCHOOL
BONDS.
IN FACT WHAT I SEE TIME AND TIME
AGAIN.
OUR VOTER STEPPING UP TO BE A
SUPPORT LOCAL SCHOOLS.
SO THIS IS AN ISSUE RELATED TO
CONFUSION I HAVE NOT SEEN BROAD
CONFUSION.
OTHER FOLKS THAT I WORK.
FOR RELATED TO SCHOOL BONDS
BEING ON A LOCAL BALLOT -- I
HAVE GREAT RESPECT IS A MEMBER I
AM GONNA BE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
TODAY BUT I LIKE TO BETTER
TRAINED OVER TO THE SIM LIMóN.
AT FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE THE COMMITTEE AND OR
CLOSING STATEMENT IN AGAIN THANK
YOU SOME NUMBER FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK WITH ME ON THIS BILL
MISTER CHAIR -- AT THEPOINT OF
AB SIX TO AND IS TO REDUCE VOTER
CONFUSION AND MAKE VOTERS MORE
AWARE OF WHAT SOMETHING WOULD
COST THEM AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S A FAIR.
THING TO DO IF YOU HAVE
SOMETHING ELSE ON THE BALLOT
RIGHT NOW WE TELL THEM ABOUT ALL
THE GREAT THINGS THAT THAT MIGHT
DO THIS BILL IS GOING TO PROVIDE.
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS --
TO FOR NEW SCHOOL FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION AND WE'RE GONNA
OPEN THIS NEW PROGRAM AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND ALL
THESE THINGS AROUND THERE AND
THEN IT SAYS THIS IS WHAT IT'S
GOING TO COST PROPERTY TAXES
WILL HAVE TO BE INCREASED.
BY THIS ABOUT FOR THIS DURATION
AND SO I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
BALANCE THE GOOD WITH THE BAD
AND I THINK IF WE DO THAT WE
DON'T DECREASE.
THE CHANCES OF VOTERS WILL VOTE
FOR THIS WEEK INCREASE THE
CHANCES THE BORDERS OF OFFICE
WHEN WE TRY CONVERSELY TO SWEEP
THINGS UNDER THE RUG.
AND WE TRIED OBSCURE WHAT THINGS
ARE GONNA COST I THINK VOTERS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO VOTE NO IN
THE LITERATURE THAT YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU I THINK IT'S PROOF
OF THAT SO I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE ON A. B. SIX
DOWN.
IN OUR THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
MOTION IS ON THE FLOOR THE
MOTION IS BY THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ELECTIONS.
THANK YOU SIR ROLL CALL PLEASE
REQUIRED NOW WHERE NO ORE A LOT
MORE LIKE AYE BELL.
BILL NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
RICARDO. FOR TITLE NOW NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO WIENER.
YOU HAVE.
ONE FOR CURRENTLY ENJOYS A ONE
FOUR ONE FOUR ON THE FLOOR AND
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
ASSUME NUMBER AND WE'RE GONNA
ADD INDIVIDUALS ON AS THEY COME
IN SEC THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
BUT NOW THE MOVING FORWARD ON
TWO ITEMS IT IS THE SUMMER KALRA
SHOW.
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER NINE IN AN
ITEM NUMBER.
TEN ALL RIGHT -- IS A MEMBER
[inaudible]
WE HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AN
ITEM NUMBER NINE WHICH IS AB.
NINE FORTY EIGHT LEADING TO THE
KILEY VALLEY CONSERVATION
PROGRAM.
WITH INTERNET OVER ITEM NUMBER
TEN WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR FRUITFUL
PRESENTATION ON ITEM.
TEN ON ITEM NINE WE'RE GONNA ASK
FOR TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT AS YOU A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IT'S A MEMBER WALKING
COMMITTEE THIK SHE WORKS THERE.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
THE OPTION PRISON AS A LEGAL.
NINE FORTY EIGHT IT ESTABLISHES
THE KILEY BY CONSERVATION
PROGRAM -- KILEY VALLEY'S NESS
BETWEEN THE FAST GROWING URBAN
CHORUS SOUNDS IN THE TOWN OF
MORGAN HILLS AND DIVERT NATURAL
HAIR CULTURAL LANDSCAPE.
PROVIDES AN ESSENTIAL QUARTER
FOR WILDLIFE MOVEMENT TO THE
SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS THE DIABLO
RANGE JUST LEGISLATION TO CREATE
THE KIND ABOUT CONSERVATION
PROGRAM COVERING MORE THAN.
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND ACRES FOR
REALIZING RESTORATION
PRESERVATION AND RECREATION
PROJECTS UP WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE --
AND I HAVE WOULD BE MARK
LANDGRAF THE CENTER ABOUT A OPEN
SPACE AT THE ALREADY UP WHO'S
HERE ABOUT WHOSE -- OUR SPONSOR
THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH REMEMBER SIR
WE WOKE ME COMMITTEEAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO BE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS YES ALL RIGHT AT PLEASE
FIRST AND LAST ORGANIZATION --
IN EUROPE TO MINISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MARK LANDGRAF
WITH THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN
SPACE A TORY SPONSORS OF AB.
NINE FORTY EIGHT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS OF COURSE MANY
POLICIES GOALS AND PROGRAMS THAT
ADDRESS CLIMATE MEDICATION
CLIMATE RESILIENCE.
KILEY VALLEY PROVIDES A HOST OF
BENEFITS THAT SUPPORT MANY OF
THESE GOALS AND POLICIES.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
ALREADY INVESTED IN PLANNING AND
PROTECTION OF PRIORITY HABITAT
IN THE KILEY VALLEY -- THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL'S
SUSTAINABLE AG LANDS
CONSERVATION PROGRAM FUNDED AN
AD PRESERVATION PLAN THAT
INCLUDES THE PROPOSED KILEY
VALLEY PROGRAM AREA.
AND THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY AND WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD HAVE INVESTED
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS TO PROTECT THE
REGION NOW WE NEED ACTION TO
PROTECT THE LANDS AT HIGHEST
RISK OF DEVELOPMENT.
AND WE NEED THE STATE'S
ASSISTANCE AND FUNDING PROJECTS
WE BELIEVE AB NINE FORTY EIGHT
CAN HELP ACHIEVE THESE ENDS.
THE AUTHORITY WORKS WITH MANY
LOCAL PARTNERS AND HAS GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH.
THE STATE LEGISLATORS AND
AGENCIES AT THE STATE HAVING
THIS PROGRAM AT THE AUTHORITY
KEEPS THE IMPLEMENTOR LOCAL BUT
FURTHER INVOLVES THE STATE AND
PROTECTING THIS RESOURCE.
SIGNIFICANT LOCAL SOURCES OF
FUNDING COULD FURTHER SERVE TO
MATCH FUTURE STATE FUNDING FOR
LAND PROTECTION IN KILEY VALLEY.
AND COULD SERVE AS A MODEL
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PARTICIPATION WITH
STATE SUPPORT.
THE AUTHORITY THANKS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA FOR HIS EFFORTS
OVER THE YEARS IN A SUPPORTING
PROTECTION FOR KILEY VALLEY AND
NOW AN AUTHORING EIGHTY NINE
FORTY EIGHT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL --
FOR THE PRESENTATIONS FOR WE
WELCOME YOU THOSE IN SUPPORT
PERSON LAST ORGANIZATION WELCOME
THANKS SO MUCH MISTER CHARGING
HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A GOOD MORNING.
MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS IS
AVAILABLE TELL US WHAT THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE MORNING
MA'AM.
I KNOW SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING MR CHAIR MARK FENSTER
MAKER FOR THE PENINSULA OPEN
SPACE TRUST IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT THANKS FOR
BEING HERE.
WHERE DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE
IN SUPPORT?
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR THIS IS A DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS PLEASE MR
ABOUT.
GOV FOR ME THIS IS BROWN --
SOMETHING WE WORKED ON FOR I
THINK ABOUT THIRTY YEARS -- AND
I'M REAL PLEASED TO SEE THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE HER OF IT.
AND URGE THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE
FOR THIS BILL THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FOR OUR AREA.
AND NOW OUR DISTRICT AND URGENT
AYE VOTE ON THIS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMAN -- FOR CARING THIS
BILL.
THIS IS A VICE CHAIR JUST -- FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S NOT FROM THE AREA
COULD YOU HELP BALANCE OUT.
OF THE NEED FOR HOUSING.
YES I AND WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE
BEEN BUILDING A LOT OF HOUSING
IN SAN JOSE I THINK WE'VE BEEN
DOING A LOT MORE IN FILL IN
AREAS WHERE -- I THINK IT'S MORE
APPROPRIATE AND SO THIS IS TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT BY THE BY THE CITY
IS HOUSING AS WELL IN TERMS OF
LOOKING FOR THEIR GENERAL PLAN
GOING FORWARD AS TO WHERE THEY
WANT HOUSING I SUPPOSE WHERE
THEY WANT TO PRESERVE PLANNED
IT'S BEEN A IT'S BEEN A PROCESS.
THOUGH ETCETERA BELL LOOTED --
TO OVER MANY DECADES THERE WAS A
PLAN BROUGHT ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS
AGO -- TO BUILD ON THIS SAY IN
THIS AREA A CITY THE SIZE OF
ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
WE'VE MOVED VERY FAR AWAY FROM
THAT BECAUSE OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS PARTICULAR LAND.
IN TERMS ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT
AS WELL AS A WILDLIFE CORRIDOR --
IS THE LAST OPEN SPACE IN THE
REGION AND SO -- IT'S ABSOLUTELY
PART OF MOVING FORWARD IN TERMS
OF THE HOUSING OPEN SPACE JOBS
BALANCE THAT THE CITY IS SAN
JOSE IN THE REGION.
HE'S TAKING INTO ACCOUNT AND
THIS I THINK CLOSE WELL WITH
THOSE WITH THOSE PLANS.
THANK YOU MISTER BASICALLY.
THANK YOU VERY SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
MOTION THE FLOOR.
INITIAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I DO WANT TO
THANK SENATOR BILL FRIST
PARTNERSHIP AND LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE OF GAS WHEN I BOUGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOME AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER KALRA THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER BELL FOR ALL
YOUR WORK.
DO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS IS THE
MOTION SENSORS RIFIC PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
HI.
OR LIKE I BELT.
HI HERTZBERG.
RICARDO.
RICARDO AYE NIELSEN.
HI WIENER.
OKAY THAT THAT IS A FIVE ZERO
BIPARTISAN VOTE THINKING SO MUCH.
NUMBER EIGHTEEN CAN YOU LOSS DUE
TO MAKE A QUICK -- MEETING UP
HERE IN WE'RE GONNA GET OUT PAS
BUTTON FOR TWO MINUTES THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU
GEN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE TAKING UP ITEM
NUMBER TEN THIS IS AB -- ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO FOCUSING ON LODGING
ESTABLISHMENTS.
WE HAVE A DOUBLE HEADER BY THE
GOOD TO SOME WOMEN FROM SAN JOSE.
WE'RE GOING TO TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO SOME NEVER KALRA AN AB.
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO SOME
INDIVIDUALS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS SHARED.
THE PROLIFERATION OF SINGLE USE
PLASTIC WASTE IS HAVING A
DEVASTATING IMPACT OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OVERWHELMING
LANDFILLS.
THOSE TINY PLASTIC SHAMPOO
BOTTLES THAT ARE COMMON IN HOTEL
OOMS REPRESENT A SIZEABLE
AMOUNT OF WAYS THAT CAN BE
EASILY ELIMINATED MORE COST
EFFECTIVE.
AND ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
ALTERNATIVES.
SENATE BILL THAT IS SIXTY TWO
WOULD RESTRICT HOTELS AND OTHER
LODGING ESTABLISHES REPLACING
SMALL SINGLE USE BOTTLES OF
SHAMPOO CONDITIONER ABOUT SO.
IN GUEST ROOMS OR BATHROOMS BY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THREE FOR
LARGE HOTELS AND JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR HOTELS A FIFTY ROOMS
ARE LESS.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE FACT THAT
EACH ROOM CAN GENERATE UP TO ONE
THOUSAND TINY BOTTLES PER YEAR?
WHICH REALLY MEANS ABOUT A
HUNDRED WHICH REALLY MEANS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF BOTTLES
A YEAR IN CALIFORNIA ALONE.
THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC WASTE
DESTINED LANDFILLS ROOM WE ARE
REMOVING IS SIGNIFICANT.
ALSO IT IS NOT FEASIBLE.
THESE PASTA BOTTLES TO BE
MANAGED AND RECYCLE BECAUSE
THEIR SMALL SIZE AND THE
RESIDUAL PRODUCT LEFT IN THE
BOTTLES -- ON AVERAGE ONLY ABOUT
30% OF THE PRODUCT IS USED IN
EACH BOTTLE.
WHAT THE BILL PREMIUMS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS GOING FORWARD FROM
ADOPTING ORDINANCES ON LODGING
ESTABLISHMENTS FOR PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS AND PLASTIC BOTTLES HAS
DEFINED THE BILL?
THIS IS JUSTIFIED BECAUSE THERE
IS VALUE IN A STATE STANDARD
THAT HOTEL BRANDS CAN COMPLY
WITH AND THERE'S AN EXPECTATION.
OTHER THEY CAN MEET RATHER THAN
HAVING FIFTY SIXTY DIFFERENT
RULES TO ABIDE BY.
THIS BILL HAS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AS WELL AS
THE PRIMARY INDUSTRY TRADE
ORGANIZATION THE CALIFORNIA
HOTEL AND LODGING ASSOCIATION.
WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS SUPERVISORS ZACH FRIEND OF
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND JOHN
CALLED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION.
REMEMBER WE'RE GRATEFUL THE
SUPERVISORS HERE HEY DOING TO
PROVIDE YOU THINK YOU ABOUT
COMMITTEE INTO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOUR TWO MINUTES SIR.
BUT MR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE --
AS A PRINCE WATER THE ORIGINAL
ORDINANCE IT'S HONOR TO BE HERE
TODAY IN FRONT OF YOU -- WE WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE INDUSTRY
AND LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
TO CREATE AN ORDINANCE THAT
COULD BE REPLICATED AS STATEWIDE
LEVEL THAT WE KNEW WOULD BENEFIT
BOTH THE INDUSTRY AS WELL AS OUR
LOCAL ENVIRONMENT.
OUR NUMBER ONE LOCAL ECONOMY
COMPONENT IS TOURISM TOURISM
SPECIFICALLY ON THE COASTAL SIDE
OF CALIFORNIANS YOU KNOW PLASTIC
WASTE WATER WAYS AS WELL SABRINA
VARMINT.
IS PRETTY SIGNIFICANT WE THOUGHT
THAT THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WE
COULD DO THAT WAS ACTIONABLE AND
REASONABLE -- WE HELP CRAFT A
BILL WITH THE ASSOCIATION THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD
WORK FOR THEM THAT WOULD REDUCE
THEIR COSTS AND ALSO HAVE A
REASONABLE TIME WHEN FOR
IMPLEMENTATION -- SOME OF THE
LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS ARE LOCAL
HOTELS HAVE ALREADY STARTED
IMPLEMENTING IT WITHIN OUR
COUNTY OF SAID THAT IT'S REDUCE
COSTS AND BEEN EASIER -- THING
FOR THEM TO MANAGE IT'S BEEN
NOTHING BUT SUCCESS OF OUR LOCAL
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SAID MY LEVEL.
SUPERVISOR NETWORK AND ACTUALLY
SEE THIS UP -- IN MY NECK OF THE
WOODS ON THE NORTH COAST AS WELL
AS INSIDE ORIGINAL INVITATION SO
WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THE
LEADERSHIP IS WELL -- OF COURSE
IS A MEMBER KALRA FOR AYE HIM
TAKEN THE SIGN WE KNOW WE'RE
TROUBLING CALLED WELLS IN
COMMITTEE.
WATCH OUT -- IT HE DID NOT BRING
ANY BOTTLES -- SO TODAY THERE WE
GO CALDWELL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR WE WALK ME AT THE END JUST
WANTED MOM TO ALSO RECOGNIZE NOT
EVERY DAY.
THAT YOU HAVE THE INDUSTRY IN
SUPPORT OF AN ISSUE LIKE THIS SO --
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH THE SOME MEMBER ON
THIS FLOOR IS YOURS SIR TWO
MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
JOHN CALDWELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION.
THE INDUSTRY ALREADY IS TAKING
INNOVATIVE STEPS TO CREATE MORE
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE -- INTER
INTER CONTINENTAL HOTEL GROUPS
IS LISTED ON THE S. AND P. DOW
JONES SUSTAINABILITY INDEX
HILTON IS REDUCE LANDFILL WASTE
BY 41%.
HI IT IS COMMITTED TO DIVERTING
40% OF ITS WAYS TO LANDFILLS --
MARRIOTT LESTER MARRIOTT
ANNOUNCED PLANS TO INSTALL B	C
DISPENSERS AND FOREIGNER FIFTY
PROPERTIES INCLUDING HIGH AND
FACILITIES LIKE THE RITZ CARLTON.
AND MARRIOTT'S NOT ALONE ALL
ACROSS.
THE STATE IN THE COUNTRY THE
INDUSTRY -- FROM BED AND
BREAKFAST ECONOMY HOTELS TO
LUXURY HOTELS ARE PHASING OUT
PLASTICS -- SO WE SUPPORT ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO WE ONE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR WAS FOUR ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO BECAUSE IT ALLOWS.
THE TIME NEEDED FOR THIS
TRANSITION AND IT DOES IT IN A
UNIFORM AND PREDICTABLE MANNER --
SO WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH US -- TO TO
COME TO THIS COME TO THIS
CONCLUSION TO IT AND AGAIN WE
SUPPORT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CALDWELL LIVE
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE WE'RE
GONNA WELCOME ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD FIRST CLASS ORGANIZATION
GOOD MORNING AFTERNOON.
OR MORNING OR MOURNING REAL GOOD
COVERAGE ON BEHALF OF SURFRIDER
HEAL THE BAY AND THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING NATALIE MAX ON
BEHALF OF RETHINK WASTE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU NATALIE.
WE'RE GONNA DO A LAST CALL LAST
CALL FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
LOOKING FOR LAST CALL.
NOW GOING TO TURN OVER THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
BRING TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE THE BILL TO SEE IF WE
HAVE QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONVERSATION CENTER TARA
[inaudible]
SO.
AIR I WANTED TO ASK IF WE HAVE A
A ANY IDEA IF THIS WILL COST ANY
IT.
IF THERE'S A COST TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
I DON'T BELIEVE THERE WILL BE
ANY COST IN ADDITION TO COST THE
ALREADY HAVE IN TERMS OF
PERMITTING AND AND APPROVAL I
MEAN THE WITH THE REALITY S
THAT -- THIS IS NOT TO AND AND
WE'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR -- AN
INTENTION OF HAVING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR ANY.
OF THE GOVERNMENT -- OFFICIAL
GOING INTO ROOMS AND AND LOOKING
UP TO SEE IF HOTELS ARE
COMPLYING OR NOT I THINK THIS IS
GONNA BE.
A BOTH A SELF POLICING AS WELL
AS CUSTOMER.
RECOGNITION MODEL CUSTOMERS WILL
KNOW WHETHER IS HAPPENING OR NOT
BUT THERE'S NO BELIEVE THAT'LL
BE A COST OF GOVERNMENT BECAUSE
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT IF THEY DO --
THE END UP HAVING A CITATION
BECAUSE CERTAINLY RECOVER THAT
COST WITH THE WITH THE
SUBSEQUENT VIOLATIONS.
AND DO WE HAVE ANY CLARIFICATION
ON IN TERMS OF WHETHER CHARTER
CITIES WILL BE SUBJECT TO THE
BILL'S BAN -- WITH THIS OF THIS
OF WITH APPLY TO OF THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY WHETHER THEY'RE IN
CHARTER CITIES.
UNINCORPORATED I MEAN REALLY
IT'S A IT'S ACROSS THE BOARD
POLICY THAT WOULD SLOWLY PHASE
OUT THE USE OF SINGLE USE
PLASTIC.
OKAY AND THEN JUST -- TO JUST
CLARIFY THERE IS A A A A FEES
INVOLVED IN TERMS OF IF YOU'RE
FOUND -- IN VIOLATION OF THE BAN
IS THAT CORRECT THE IN THE IN
ITS INITIALLY A WARNING LETTER.
THAT WARNING THAT THAT'S THAT'S
THE INTENTION IS IS -- TO HAVE A
WARNING LETTER SENATE THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION -- DETERMINES THAT --
THERE'S A HOTEL THAT'S NON
COMPLIANCE -- BUT I THINK THE
FACT WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY THE GOOD THING ABOUT
THATIS THAT GIVING THEM THE
THREE TO FOUR YEARS ALLOWS THE
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNMENT YOU KNOW THE THE
STATE AND THE INDUSTRY TOGETHER
TO GET THE WORD OUT. TO TO
HOTELS AND MOTELS AND MAKE SURE
THEY'RE IN COMPLIANCE AND THEY
NEED ASSISTANCE.
THE THE TO HAVE THEIR PRIMARY
TRADE GROUP IN SUPPORT I THINK
IS A REALLY GOOD POSITION TO BE
AND AND AND MANY PHOTOS ALREADY
MOVING THAT DIRECTION BUT THEN
THIS YEAR MARRIOTT.
BUT TO BE UNDER PROPERTIES NORTH
AMERICA ALREADY PAYS OUT OF
SINGLE USE PLASTIC AND SO IT'S
ALREADY THE DRUG TO THE INDUSTRY
PARTLY BECAUSE IT DOES SAVE THE
MONEY.
AND THE THREE TO FOUR YEAR LEAD
TIME TO GET THEM.
EVEN THE SMALLER OPERATORS TIME
OF THE FOUR YEARS WE GIVE
SMALLER OPERATORS THE TIME -- IN
A BASIN AND SO I THINK FOR TODAY
AND I'M GOING TO JUST LAY OFF
THE BILL JUST BECAUSE I WANT TO
BE ABLE TO DIG A LITTLE BIT MORE
INTO IT -- BUT YOU KNOW THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT I A WILL
OPPOSE OR SUPPORTED ON THE FLOOR
IF IF AND WHEN IT DOES GET THERE
BUT I JUST WANTEDTO PUT THAT
THERE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT I
DO SOME MORE RESEARCH.
YOU KNOW LOOK INTO IT A BIT MORE
ON MY OWN AND THE IMPACTS ON ON
THE DISTRICT.
THE IN IT BUT I DON'T KNOW IF
THE IF YOU LIKE TO HEAR THE
SUPERVISOR TALK ABOUT THE LOCAL
IMPACT ANYMORE OR IF.
THAT BE HELPFUL AT ALL TO YOU
THOSE ARE ALL THE QUESTIONS I
HAVE FOR TODAY.
THANK YOU BECAUSE IT CENTER.
WHAT WHAT OF SAVING ON TWO ITEMS --
IN THEIR TURN OVER THE VICE
CHAIR I THINK ON THE ISSUE OF
CHARTER CITIES.
YES THERE'S A BELIEF I THINK
THAT IS A MEMBER WANTS TO BE AND
I DON'T EVER PUT WORDS IN THE
SOME MEMBERS MATH THAT BEING
EXPLICIT ON THAT ISSUE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S GONNA BE POURED I
THAT MAYBE.
SOME FURTHER CONVERSATION DOWN
THE ROAD AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
INDUSTRY WOULD SUPPORT THAT AS
WELL.
THAT'S CORRECT -- SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT YEAH A DECEPTIVE THE
CLARIFICATION MAKING SURE THAT'S
EXPLICIT.
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IT'S
IMPORTANT AND AGAIN JUST WANTED
TO COME A MOMENT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THIS IN THE REFER TACK ON
THIS ISSUE -- IN INCREASES IN
NUMBER BUT PUSH BACK ON THE IF
YOU THINK I'M INCORRECT I THINK
ON THE ISSUE OF WHY YOU'RE
LOOKING AT STATEWIDE IS TO BE
ABLE.
TO TRY TO BETTER YOU BRING IN A
FORMAL -- Là CRY SO THAT
EVERYONE BIG OR SMALL -- IS
SUBJECT TO THAT -- BUT THEY'RE
MOST LIKELY WON'T BE A WHOLE LOT
OF LOCAL ENFORCEMENT BUT TRYING
TO GET A STREAMLINED THAT AND I
WOULD.
CHARACTERIZE THE COST OF MINOR
YEAH -- IF NOT OBSERVABLE ACROSS
THE STATE.
THAT'S CORRECT POSTURE AND THE
THE UNIFORMITY IS CRITICAL
ESPECIALLY FOR THE INDUSTRY --
IMAGINE IF YOU HAVE ONE JUST SIX
AND THAT'S GOING TO BAN LOTION
ANOTHER ONE TO PAY IS ANOTHER
ONE IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE A
DIFFERENT KIND OF DISPENSER THAN
THE ONE ACROSS THE STREET.
THE CITY ACROSS THE STREET.
AND THAT'S I THINK WHY WAS WILL
BE ABLE TO WORK SO WELL WITH
INDUSTRY IS AT THE RECOGNITION
THAT.
THAT -- YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CRUZ TAKE
LEADERSHIP.
OTHER CITIES COUNTIES MAY VERY
WELL FOLLOW I THINK HAVING A
UNIFORM WILL NOT ONLY GET THIS
IN PLACE MORE QUICKLY -- BUT
ACROSS THE BOARD BUT IT PREVENTS
THESE ONE OFFS WHICH WOULD MAKE
IT REALLY CHALLENGING FOR THE
INDUSTRY AND FRANKLY FOR THE
STATE. TO BE ABLE TO REGULATE
AND MONITOR IN A WAY THAT MAKES
SENSE FOR REDUCING THE PLASTIC
AS WELL AS BEING TOO ONEROUS FOR
THE INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR IN TURN
OVER THE VICE CHAIR MS VICE
CHAIR.
YOU.
FAIR SOMETIMES -- WE GET TO
WATCH INDUSTRY AND THEY'RE THE
KIND OF SELF REGULATE AND START
TAKING CARE OF THE CONCERNS OVER
HEARING TESTIMONY THAT THE MAJOR
CHAINS ARE.
ALREADY MOVING IN A CERTAIN
DIRECTION SO I'VE.
KIND OF WANT.
TO MAYBE HAS SOME.
SIMPLE QUESTIONS JUST SO THAT I
CAN ANSWER THEM WHEN I GET OUT
IN PUBLIC HERE -- THE FIRST IS
IF IF THEY'RE VOLUNTARILY.
MAKING GREAT MOVES OUT WHY THE
NEED FOR THE BILL.
I THINK THAT THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION I THINK PART OF IT IS
THAT YES THE INDUSTRY IS MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION INDUSTRY HAS
TENDED TO BE A FOR THINKING WHEN
IT COMES IN BY MAIL ISSUES.
HOWEVER A THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE
A UNIFORM RULE THAT PUTS A TIME
LINE IN PLACE THAT'S ACCOUNTABLE
TIMELINE FOR THE INDUSTRY IN
ORDER TO GET BOTH THE LARGEST
MOTELS.
ON BOARD -- IT IN FRANKLY IT'S
AS IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT IF THE
INDUSTRY WASN'T GOING IN THAT
DIRECTION FOLKS SAY WELL WHY YOU
PUSHING INDUSTRY THAT'S NOT
READY YET.
WHAT INDUSTRY SHOWS AND IS READY
I THINK THIS IS ACTUALLY THE
OPPORTUNE TIME FOR US TO PUT IN
A STATE RULE THAT'S UNIFORM --
AND AGAIN I THINK THAT IT WOULD
BE.
A REALLY -- BACK.
TO THE VERY CHALLENGING FOR THE
INDUSTRY IF YOU START GETTING TO
AT TEN TWENTY THIRTY ORDINANCES
AND SO I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
TIMING IS ACTUALLY PERFECT IN
THAT SENSE.
BECAUSE SINCE THE INDUSTRY'S
ALREADY MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION
IF WE DO NOTHING.
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS I CAN ALMST
GUARANTEE THEY'LL BE AT LEAST A
DOZEN DIFFERENT LOCAL ORDINANCES
IN PLACE THEN THE INDUSTRY TO
COME TO US TO SAY CAN YOU JUST
MAKE A UNIFORM RULE.
AND THE WILL HAVE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SAYING WAIT A
SECOND YOU TAKE MY LOCAL
PREEMPTION RATCHET GETTING AHEAD
OF THAT BY MAKING A UNIFORM RULE
ACROSS THE STATE RIGHT NOW.
SO THAT OTHER JURISDICTIONS
DON'T EVEN HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
ISSUE THEY ALREADY KNOW THEY'RE
DOING THAT THAT THE STATE IS
ALREADY WORKING ON PHASING OUT
THIS PLASTIC.
AND I THINK IT PUTS US IN A
POSITION WHERE.
INDUSTRY WE'RE DOING WHAT'S
RIGHT RIGHT FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR THE INDUSTRY IN
TERMS OF REDUCING THEIR COSTS
BUT ALSO.
PREVENTS -- THE THIRTY DIFFERENT
RULES FOR INDUSTRY DATA BYE BYE --
WHEN -- HOTEL GUESTS ARRIVED
THERE USED TO ALWAYS LITTLE BOND
YEAH.
OTHER GOING TO GET.
DISPENSERS TYPICALLY WILL BE
DISPENSERS AND OTHER ACTION I'VE
BEEN TO A NUMBER OF HOTELS ARE
TRAVEL WERE YOU SEE DISPENSERS
THAT ARE IN PLACE THERE SECURE
THEIR SAFE -- THEIR BILLABLE IN
A SAFE MANNER AND BY THE WAY --
THE LITTLE BOTTLES ARE STILL
AVAILABLE AT THE FRONT DESK --
IN SO IF THE HOTEL WNTS TO MAKE
THE OFFER THEM AT THE FRONT DESK
FOR FOR THOSE I STILL WANT. TO
HAVE THEM THEY CAN ORDER THEIR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES THAT
FOR SOME REASON CAN'T USE A
DISPENSER THE MAYBE THE ROOM
THERE THE THOSE OPTIONS ALSO BE
AVAILABLE AND THOSE TO BE ABLE
TO SELL.
LITTLE BOTTLES AT THE HOTEL SHOP
AS WELL AS JUST INSIDE THE
ACTUAL BATHROOM OF THE ROOMS.
YOU'RE A GREAT LAST QUESTION --
A BABY LIKE SQUEEZE TUBES LIKE
YOU KNOW WE GET LITTLE LIKE.
MUSTARD AND KETCHUP.
FOR AT FAST FOODS BUT IF WE GET
SHAMPOO AND CONDITIONER AND
TUBES THAT CREATE ANOTHER
PROBLEM OR OR ORDERS
DISPENSARIES PROBABLY THE MOST
LIKELY ROUTE THAT MOST OF THESE
HOTELS ARE GOING TO TAKE I THINK
IT'S TO SPENCER BECAUSE OF IT'S
UNLIKELY THE INDUSTRIES IS GOING
TO GO TO ANOTHER.
SMALL.
ITEM BECAUSE IT'S NOT GONNA SAY
THE MANY MONEY.
AND IT'S NOT GONNA BE PRACTICAL
FOR THEM I THINK THE PRACTICAL
MOVE IS TO GO IN THE DIRECTION
WHERE THEY HAD THESE DISPENSERS
AND MANY OF THOSE KEYS TUBES ARE
PLASTIC AS WELL AS THEY WOULDN'T
COMPLY.
WITH -- WITH THIS PARTICULAR
BILL SO THAT OUR PAPER OPTIONS
ARE SOMETIMES ARE SOAPS THERE IN
PAPER AND ALL THAT THAT'S FINE
SO THOSE WILL BE OPTIONS -- FOR
THE HOTELS AND I'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN SEEN -- IN A HOTEL
RELATIVELY RECENTLY IS CISCO
WHERE THEY HAD LARGER --
DISPENSERS OR LARGER BOTTLES ARE
SECURED AND THEN THEY HAD A
LITTLE SIGN MARKETING THE
PRODUCTS THAT HELP YOU REALLY
LIKE THIS PRODUCT THERE FOR SALE
FOR TWELVE DOLLARS A BOTTLE TEN
ARE YOU.
WILL BRING A TEAR ROOM SO --
THERE SO OPPORTUNITIES FOR VOTE
FOR THE COMP THE PERSONAL CARE
COMPANIES TO MARKET THEIR
PRODUCTS AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK FOR MUCH SERVER
CALLER THINKING.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR LOOK
AT LOOK AT THIS AS WE TOOK WE IS
THE STATE TOOK THE WRONG
APPROACH WHEN IT COMES TO
PLASTIC BAGS -- WE DIDN'T HAVE A
BACKBONE TO BE ABLE TO BAN
PLASTIC BAGS.
AND THEN LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
TAKE THE LEAD AND IT TOOK NEARLY
A DECADE IN BILLIONS OF PLASTIC
BAGS BILL TO GET OUR ACT
TOGETHER -- AND LOOK AT THIS AS
PUT IN THE WORK IN THE FRONT END
WORKING COLLABORATIVE THE
INDUSTRY AND VICE VERSA GIVE IT
A LOOK AND ESTABLISH LAW -- THAT
IS UNIFORM ACROSS.
THE STATE.
THANKS TO LEADERSHIP -- IN SANTA
CRUZ A VERY GRATEFUL FOR TAKEN
THAT FOR SLEEP IT IS NEVER EASY.
I'M A SUPERVISOR SO DO
APPRECIATE AT MANTECH MOMENTS I
THINK IT IS A MEMBER. FOR ALL OF
HIS EFFORT HOW COULD THIS IS NOT
BEEN EASY -- IN LATELY WE'RE
USING WHAT'S THE NUMBER OF
PLASTIC BOTTLES ARE BEING USED
ACROSS THE STATE RIGHT NOW BUT
IT'S IT'S HARD TO TELL AS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS CAUSES BY
ASSN IS A THOUSAND PER HOTEL
ROOM FOR YEARS THE AVERAGE.
GO AHEAD CAN MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE IN DO APPRECIATE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL AND WOULD YOU
ALSO LIKE TO OFFER MOTIONS AND
WINNER.
OF HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL -- I I
GOT MY POLICY OF PRESENTING
ANOTHER -- COMMITTEES SORRY FOR
MISSING YOUR PRESENTATION -- ONE
OF THANK YOU -- I THINK THE
INDUSTRY THANK AMONG FOR WORKING
TOGETHER THIS IS SO IMPORTANT --
AND I KNOW YOU KNOW ANY OF MY
RECENT HOTEL AND YOU USE YOUR
10% OF THE BOTTLE IN THE BOTTLES
GONE.
I'M SURE YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT
OR AND WE NEED TO STOP
STRUGGLING THE PLANET EMPLOYEES
IN THE OCEANS OF THIS IS A
REALLY GREAT IDEA THANK YOU CAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
THIS IS A DO PASS.
DO PASSAGE JUDICIARY SIMILAR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND AND
FOR YOU AND YOUR STAFF WORK --
ON THIS AND WORKING WITH MY
STAFF -- AND I WE WOULDN'T BE
HERE TODAY BUT WASN'T FOR
SUPERVISOR FRIEND IS LEADERSHIP --
IN MOVING THIS FORWARD AT A
LOCAL LEVEL TO BE ABLE TO MODEL
SOMETHING OUT WHAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DOES -- WHICH I THIN
IS A GREAT WAY FOR US TO KIND OF
BUILD LEGISLATION.
WE ALSO WOULD BE IF IT WASN'T
FOR THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION BEFORE I EVEN
INTRODUCED A BILL I BROUGHT THEM
INTO MY OFFICE SAY OKAY.
I HAVE AN IDEA THE START WORKING
ON THIS FROM DAY ONE AND THEY'VE
BEEN PHENOMENON AND SO I REALLY
WANT TO THANK THEM.
I ALSO THINK IT'S AN AMBER STONE --
WHO'S BEEN A PARTNER IN THIS AND
HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL AS A THANK
YOU SO MUCH HE SHARES BUT GAS
FROM A BOAT THANK YOU SEVENTY
SEVEN SUPERVISOR NICE WORK SIR
THANKS FOR BEING HERE CALDWELL
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
MISSING JUST A ROLL CALL PLEASE
WIRE HI.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
FIRST REGARD HER TITLE
[inaudible]
NIELSEN.
WIENER WIENER HI.
CURRENTLY CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
THREE ZERO VOTE OR KEEP THAT
ROLE OPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I GRATEFUL.
HE'S PRESS ACKERMAN -- WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT UP ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT MISTER MCCARTY.
IS IS AB.
EIGHT SIXTY NINE THE FOCUS IS ON
A PILOT PROJECT ESPECIALLY FOR
SMUGGLE.
THIS REGARDING THE WALKING ME TO
COMMITTEE ACTION I GUESS WHICH
IS A WELCOME BACK YOU HAVE BEEN
A FREQUENT FLYER AS OF LATE AND
WE LOVE IT.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR FIND AB
SIX EIGHTY NINE OKAY
[inaudible]
MR CINNAMON.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING THIS IS A
A A DISTRICT BILLS YOU KNOW TO
RELATE TO OUR MUNICIPAL.
UTILITIES RESTRICTS MIND.
THIS WOULD GIVE SOME PARITY TO
WHAT CURRENTLY HAPPENS WITH THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES WERE
THE ENTITIES MIGHT COULD RECEIVE
NON STOCK EQUITY IN THE COMPANY.
US MIGHT AS WE KNOW IS OUR
ELECTRIC PROVIDER FOR THE
SACRAMENTO REGION IT'S A PUBLIC
pAGENCY -- GREAT CUSTOMER SERVICE
PROVIDING LOW RATES A LOWER THAN
OUR INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES A-RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYER CIVIC CLEAN
GAZE AT THE FOREFRONT.
INDY CARBON ISING ARE GREETED --
RIGHT NOW SMUD WORKS WITH
BUSINESSES TO GIVE THEM THEIR
EXPERTISE ELECTRICITY EMPOWER
MANAGEMENT.
IS SIX IT'S A VERY HELPFUL THESE
EMERGING GREEN TECHNOLOGIES
WHICH ARE USUALLY IN THE START
UP PHASE -- IF THE START UPS ARE
PURCHASED AS IT HAPPENED THE
PAST BY OTHER COMPANIES AS BUT
HASN'T BEEN ABLE. TO TO GET
VALUE WITH THAT AND THIS WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO GET A LITTLE BIT
OF VALUE ON THE EQUITY THEY'VE
BEEN PROVIDING AS I SAID.
THIS WOULD BRING PARITY TO WHAT
OUR IDEA USE CAN DO.
THIS WITHOUT THE DUAL BENEFIT OF
ENCOURAGING DEVELOPMENT OF GREEN
TECHNOLOGIES TO HELP US REACH
REACH OUR AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS.
AND ALSO OFFSETTING RATE
INCREASES FOR OUR LOCAL
CUSTOMERS TO HELP REACH THESE
GOALS -- FAIRNESS ISSUE THE RATE
PAYERS AS MUCH AT THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES TO SEE A RETURN ON
THEIR INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
AS TO THE SHAREHOLDERS WITH PGD
IN ADDISON SO FORTH I WITH ME
ARE REPRESENTED FROM SMUD AS
WELL AS SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION.
ASK YOUR IDOLS THANK YOU.
IF YOU SO MUCH WE ARE GONNA HAVE
TO INDIVIDUALS -- BE ABLE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN
EACH INDIVIDUAL IT HAS TWO
MINUTES -- THEN OBVIOUSLY WILL
OPEN UP FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO BE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT SO WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO KICK US OFF
FIRST OF THE TWO WELCOME SIR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
FIRST LASSEN ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
THANK YOU MY NAME'S MARK RAWSON --
I'M THE MANAGER OF NEW BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT FOR SOME ODD.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY -- FOR LET ME PRESENT --
THIS TESTIMONY TODAY -- WERE THE
SIX LARGEST A COMMUNITY OWNED
ELECTRIC SERVICE PROVIDERS IN
THE COUNTRY -- SECOND LARGEST IN
CALIFORNIA WE SERVE ABOUT ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION -- CUSTOMERS
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SMALL
PORTIONS OF A PLASTER YOLO.
COUNTIES -- I WANT TO THINK --
THE COMMITTEE ALSO FOR WORKING
WITH US AND SOME OF THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO TO THIS -- TO THIS
BILL.
SO SMART HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
WORKING WITH CUT COMPANIES ON
VARIOUS PRODUCTS AND SERVICES
THAT PROVIDE INNOVATIVE --
SOLUTIONS PRODUCTS AND
TECHNOLOGIES TO ADDRESS ENERGY
AFFORDABILITY AND RELIABILITY.
AND WE CONTINUE TO DO SO TODAY
AS SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS WILL
BE NEEDED IN NEW TECHNOLOGIES
GRID MODERNIZATION ENERGY
RESOURCES AND ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION. TO ME
CALIFORNIA'S GARB CARBON
REDUCTION IN CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
FOR SOME OF THESE PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES.
MODE PROVIDES ACCESS TO ITS OWN
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY -- WE
DEVOTE STAFF TIME -- WE PROVIDE
CRITICAL FIELD TESTING
OPPORTUNITIES -- FOR THESE
TECHNOLOGIES -- AND WHILE WE GET
THE PRODUCT THAT WE NEED
COMPANIES THAT WE PARTNER WITH
ME THEN CAPITALIZE ON OUR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THEIR PRODUCT.
BY MARKETING THESE PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES TO OTHER UTILITIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
AT A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
PROFIT TO THEM BUT NOT
NECESSARILY SMARTER JUST MUCH
CUSTOMERS. FOR INSTANCE SEVERAL
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WE INVESTED
TIME AND EFFORT WITH A COMPANY
TO DEVELOP A SIGNIFICANT NEW
SOFTWARE PRODUCT.
THAT ANALYZES METER DATA TO
COMPARE CUSTOMER ENERGY USAGE
FOR CUSTOMERS.
THIS COMPANY WAS ACQUIRED --
SUBSEQUENTLY -- TO THAT THAT
ASSISTANCE FROM SMUD AND THAT
COMPANY WAS ACQUIRED AND SOLD
FOR MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IF WE HAD NEGOTIATED NON STOCK
SECURITY IN THAT COMPANY OUR
CUSTOMERS WOULD HAVE BENEFITTED
FROM A FINANCIAL RETURN PAID
THIS MONTH FOR OUR CONTRIBUTION
TO THAT PRODUCT -- THE TIMES
PARTICULAR RIGHT FIRST MONTH
INVESTMENTS TO BE FAIRLY
COMPENSATED.
AS MUCH AS PLANNING TO SPEND A
LITTLE OVER SIX BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS TO
HELP US ACHIEVE OUR NET ZERO
CARBON EMISSION GOALS AS
OUTLINED IN OUR RECENTLY ADOPTED
ANGERED RESOURCE PLAN. THIRTY
SEVEN IT'S PRETTY SIGNIFICANT --
WE'RE GONNA MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS -- IN ORDER TO MEET
SOME OF THE STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY
MANDATES -- AND THIS WILL RESULT
IN INCREASES OF RATES TO OUR
CUSTOMERS TO PAY FOR THESE
INVESTMENTS.
ANY NEW REVENUE THAT RESULTS
FROM THIS BILL WILL GO DIRECTLY
TO HELP STABILIZING -- THESE
RATE INCREASES AND I THINK YOUR
TIME FOR WHEN WE TESTIFY THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT CHANGEABLE EXAMPLE
COMMITTEES WELL ON HOW THIS
WOULD IMPACT THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE?
TO PLEASE GOOD MORNING MA'AM
WELCOME IF YOU COULD JUST GIVE
US YOUR FIRST CLASS ORGANIZATION
AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
NAME IS LISA HAGERMAN I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS AT TBL
PARTNERS WERE A DOUBLE BOTTOM
LINE VENTURE CAPITAL FIRM BASED
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE INVEST FOR FINANCIAL RETURNS
AS WELL AS SOCIAL ENVIRONMENTAL
AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS IN THE
SECTORS AND REGIONS IN WHICH WE
INVEST.
WE'VE -- BEEN AROUND FIFTEEN
YEARS AND WERE EARLY INVESTORS
AND SOLAR CITY AND NOW INVESTING
OUT OF A FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FUND THAT'S IN MAN IT
INVESTING IN -- ENERGY STORAGE
SOLUTIONS SUCH AS ADVANCE MY
CAREER IT'S LUCIEN'S DVL
SUPPORTS AB SIX EIGHTY NINE AND
SPOTS EFFORT TO DRIVE INNOVATION
IN THE CLEAN ENERGY SPACE
THROUGH TEIR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY AND PRODUCTS.
SB SIX EIGHTY NINE WILL BRING TO
MARKET THE TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL
BE NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE OUR
STATES.
CLIMATE AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
GOALS.
SMUD BOARD RECENTLY ADOPTED ONE
OF THE MOST AGGRESSIVE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANS WITH A
PATH TO NET ZERO EMISSIONS BY.
TWENTY FORTY CREATING INCENTIVES
FOR USE UTILITIES TO WORK WITH
YOUNG INNOVATIVE COMPANIES HELPS
REDUCE THE RISK OF NEW START UP
INVESTMENTS.
THAT WILL ATTRACT MORE INVESTORS
LIKE DB ALL PARTNERS AND CREATE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS AS WE'VE SEEN
IN THE SOLAR INDUSTRY.
WHEN YOUNG START UPS ARE
PARTNERING WITH UTILITIES AND
OTHERS TO REFINE THEIR
TECHNOLOGIES AND PRODUCTS IT IS
OFTEN DIFFICULT TO AGREE TO
ROYALTY AGREEMENTS?
AS THOSE CAN HAMPER FUTURE
GROWTH.
HOWEVER THE PROBE THE OPTIONS
PROVIDED UNDER AB SIX EIGHTY
NINE WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR
SMUD AND START UP COMPANIES TO
FORM STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS.
THAT COULD LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT
TECHNOLOGICAL AND PRODUCT
ADVANCES.
THE B. L. PARTNERS LOOKS FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
UTILITIES AND OTHERS TO THINK
CREATIVELY. TO BE ABLE TO INVEST
AND INNOVATE TO MEET OUR CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS TO THE BENEFIT OF
THE DISTRICTS RATE PAYERS AND
OUR ENVIRONMENT THE BILL
SUPPORTS A. B..
SIX EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE
WITH LIKE TO GET A WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE WHO'S IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL [inaudible]
PLEASE.
THE MORNING AFTER THE TERM HELL
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
SITUATION.
A VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MISSION THANKS IN THINGS COULD
ISSUE SIR EGGMAN AFTER WELSH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
CESSATION IN SUPPORT OF BILL.
YOU SEE THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING RUSS BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF TO SEE OF SACRAMENTO AND
ON BEHALF OF MERIT ACOSTA BURKE
IN SUPPORT.
I DON'T THINK SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING NOT YOUR MOM ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
BRING TO A LAST CALL LAST CALL
FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
HEARING SE NINE WERE NOT GONNA
WELCOME ANYONE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO
RECEIVE ANY QUESTIONS ARE
CONVERSATIONS THE DEVICE YOU'RE
PLEASE.
MATURE I ENTRY I'M INTRIGUED BY
THIS BUT I'M ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT.
IN THIS PALACE GOING OUTSIDE OF
THEIR BASIC CORE BUSINESS I AM.
IN FACT -- MAYBE ASK MISTER
ROSSIN A COUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS
YOU.
MY RESEARCH SHOWS THAT YOU ARE
AND CALPERS.
YES AT DO YOU HAVE A FOR A ONE A
THAT YOU CAN INVEST IN FOR YOUR
EMPLOYEES THAT -- ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE DB PLAN. FOR A FOUR
ONE K. S. MONDAY ALLOWS OR ONE A
FOR ME IS PROUD OF DONE JUST
THAT.
I BELIEVE THA'S TRUE I'M NOT A
I'M NOT SURE SPECIFICALLY ON
THAT.
YOU'RE NOT IN IT -- DRUG A LOT
OF MUNICIPALITIES ALSO OFFER A
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLAN THAT
THEY CAN.
INVEST IN I HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
THEIR PAY CHECK GO OUT EVERY
EVERY EVERY EVERY PAY PERIOD --
BECAUSE I WAS THINKING PROBABLY
THE IDEAS THAT ARE BEING
GENERATED ARE BEING GENERATED BY
YOUR EMPLOYEES IS THAT CORRECT.
SEC SOME OF THE IDEAS THAT ARE
GENERATED BY SMALL EMPLOYEES WE
USED -- TO HELP THESE COMPANIES
GET THEIR PRODUCTS COMMERCIALLY
READY.
YES.
I'M JUST WONDERING IF -- IF IF
YOU WOULD YOU WOULD BE LIMITED
TO NON STOCK -- SECURITIES IF
YOU DID IT INSIDE YOUR DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN.
YOU CAN OWN STOCK YOU COULD
ACTUALLY.
MAKE IT PART OF YOUR PRIVATE
EQUITY PORTFOLIO YOU CAN WORK
WITH.
B. B. L. PARTNERS AND AND AND
OWN ACTUAL SHARES AND BENEFIT
THE EMPLOYEES WOULD BENEFIT IN
THEIR IN THEIR PRIVATE JOB.
YOU KNOW DEFINED CONTRIBUTION
PLANS AND THAT'S THAT'S RIGHT
SHE IS -- IS A SPACE WHERE THIS
WOULD BE A LOT OF FUN AND IN IF
THE RATE IT WITH THE RATES --
THAT THE UTILITIES MIGHT GET ALL
WE ALWAYS REDUCE THE
CONTRIBUTION TO THE THE DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN DID THEN
TRANSFER SOME SAVINGS ON THE
TAXPAYERS OF THE RATEPAYERS.
SO THAT WAS SORT OF THE SPACE
THAT I YEAH I SAW -- THE SEVEN
FORTY THROUGH THE CHAIR MAYBE I
CAN ADDRESS THAT TOO I THINK THE
GOAL IT WHAT WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS IS THE NOTION WELL WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT IS THAT.
ALLOWING THEM TO MAXIMIZING
THEIR CURRENT PARTNERSHIPS WITH
WHERE THERE IS NONE AND SO
WHETHER USING THOSE MONIES TO
HELP THE RATE PAYERS LOWER
POTENTIAL RATE INCREASES IN THE
FUTURE.
OR FOR THEIR YOU KNOW LONG TERM
FIXED COSTS LIKE RETIREMENT
HEALTH IT'S ALL PART OF THAT
SAME.
POOL YOU KNOW SMART HAS COST.
FURTHER ENERGY PROCUREMENT
FURTHER TRANSMISSION LINES FOR
THE WHOLE WORKS AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND SO.
I THINK IT'S KIND OF PART PARCEL
THAT IT'S A PACKAGE.
THAT WILL HAVE THIS BENEFIT TO
THE TO THE MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT WHETHER IT'S THAT
RETIREMENT OR THIS OTHER PIECE
I'M NOT SURE IF THAT'S NECESSARY.
I JUST PROVIDED.
OKAY A LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
GOVERNMENTS GETTING INVOLVED IN.
TRANSACTION SO I'M JUST TRYING
TO FIND MY COMFORT ZONE.
THANK YOU MISTER JOE THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
INDIA OF THE DECEMBER COMING ON
THIS I THINK THAT -- WITH THE
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HIS OFFICE ON
RATE PAYER PROTECTION RIGHT --
SO ALLOWING THESE INVESTMENTS TO
BE ABLE TO PROCEED.
ENSURING THAT THOSE WHO ARE RATE
PAYERS -- ARE PROTECTED AS WELL
AND I THINK THAT THE AMENDMENTS
ALSO STRIKE THAT BALANCE
CRITICALLY BEING A PUBLIC AGENCY
I DON'T KNOW IF.
THE STATE REPRESENTATIVE WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TALK ABOUT DATA
THIS IN THERE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO STRIKE
THAT BALANCE TO ALLOW FOR THE
INNOVATION.
IN TO FLOURISH WHILE ALSO SINCE
THE PUBLIC ENTITY PROTECTING THE
REPAIRS.
YEAH I THINK THERE ARE SEVERAL
SAFEGUARDS IN YOUR FROM THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE PRIOR ONE AND
ONE IS A PILOT FOR FIVE YEARS.
YOU KNOW WE LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
THESE WE CAN DO AT THREE AND A
LIMIT THE THE AMOUNT SO NO MORE
THAN 3% OF THE DISTRICT'S ANNUAL
REVENUE SO.
CAN BE SOME MASSIVE PROJECT IS
GONNA.
A NO LEVERAGE AND ANY PARTY SO I
THINK THIS IS YOU KNOW A FAIR
OPPORTUNITY TO DELVE INTO THIS
SPACE WHICH AGAIN.
OUR INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
CURRENTLY DO AND THAT BENEFITS
SHAREHOLDERS AND SO.
WHY NOT HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
BENEFIT TO TAXPAYERS WERE PART
OF THIS MISCIBLE DISTRICT?
THANK YOU SENATE PLEASE IF I
COULD JUST ADD ONE OTHER THING
TO IN A MINUTE WE TOOK IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
REQUIRES OUR BOARD TO ESTABLISH
PROCEDURES AND DO CERTAIN
ACTIONS TO BRING TRANSPARENCY TO
THESE ACTIVITIES -- THAT ALSO
PROVIDES -- SOME -- REPAIR
PROTECTION AND SOME VISIBILITY
INTO POTENTIAL CONFLICT OF
INTEREST RELATED ISSUES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALRIGHT LET ME SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
ALSO WOULD WELCOME A MOTION AT
THIS TIME.
AB WE GET A MOTION BY CENTER
TYLER WATCH OUT.
ALL RIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR IS A
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
PLEASE.
AS FOREVER THANK YOU ARE LEASING
GERMAN ONCE AGAIN THIS IS A DO
PASS TO THE FLOOR MOTION
MESSENGER SERVICE CALL THE ROLL.
HI.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HERTZBERG RICARDO.
RICARDO I NIELSEN.
WIENER WIENER HI.
HI KERN ENJOYS A THREE ZERO VOTE
WHEN HE THAT ROLE OPEN IN THE
BACK TOO SOON AS WE GET
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH I SHALL BE ALL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
REYES GERMAN.
HE SHARES A CITY BY THE BAY WITH
CENTER WIENER.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX FOCUSING ON
HOUSING IN SURPLUS LAND.
WHEN I TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER -- FOR
ALL OF HIS WORK ON THE ISSUE OF
HOUSING AS WELL AS THE SENATOR
CENTER WIENER.
DON'T FORGET SAN MATTEO COUNTY.
WELL THAT'S RIGHT IN SAN MATEO
COUNTY ABSOLUTELY MIGHT MY DAD
AB THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S JUST SENATOR MY GOODNESS.
HOUSE OR TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU -- TO SOME MEMBER TING
FOR HIS WORK WITH US OVER THE
PAST WEEK ON THIS ISSUE -- IN
HIS FANTASTIC TEAM OF THE DATA
DEEP DIVE ON THIS BILL IN.
ADVANCING THESE AMENDMENTS
THROUGH THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANKS AGAIN FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ALSO
THANK YOU TO YOU AND YOUR TEAM
WE ARE HAPPILY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK
AS WELL AS YOUR YOUR TEAM'S
GREAT WORK AND REALLY -- HAPPY
ABOUT THE COMPROMISE WE ABLE TO
FIGHT AS YOU KNOW WITH THE STATE
IS FACING IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
CRISIS IN -- TWENTY FOURTEEN I
WAS ABLE TO GET AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE SIGNED INTO LAW
WHICH ALSO AMENDED THE SURPLUS
LAND ACT.
HE GAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS OF FIRST RIGHT OF
REFUSAL FOR SURPLUS PUBLIC LANDS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE SECOND BUT LAW
WENT INTO A FACT PEOPLE TRY TO
CIRCUMVENT A WE HAVE A SITUATION
THE CITY OF OAKLAND THAT WENT TO
A PRIVATE DEVELOPER SAID ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER.
CIRCUMVENT THAT ENTIRE PROCESS
WE HAVE THE CITY OF BURLINGAME
CREATING A HEALTH DISTRICT WHAT
THEY PROPOSED TO BUILD SENIOR
HOUSING BUT NO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO.
THE THE AGAIN THAT.
THE LAWS OF STATED NOW SAYS THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
HAVE TO GET THAT FIRST RIGHT OF
REFUSAL YOU DON'T HAVE TO SELL
IT TO THEM.
BUT THEY AT LEAST HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO NEGOTIATE WITH
THAT GOVERNMENT AGENCY TO GO GET.
THAT PROPERTY -- WHAT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX DOES IT
CLARIFIES THIS PROVISION OF
SURPLUS LAND AS WELL AS THE
DEFINITION OF SURPLUS LAND?
IT ALSO CREATES A STATEWIDE
DATABASE OF LOCAL SURPLUS PLANTS.
IT ALSO LEVERAGES OUR HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW TO PROMOTE IN USE --
BUT THE AND THE USE OF THE
SURPLUS LAND ACTS SO WITH THAT
WE HAVE -- TO GREAT WITH THIS
SPOKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF S. BY
THE A. B..
FORTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
SOMEONE WE'RE GONNA ASK OUR
WITNESSES TO PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TWO MINUTES WE WELCOME
YOU WOULD LIKE ME TO KEEP HIS.
ALL RIGHT AT FIRST MY SAME
ORGANIZATION WE WELCOME YOU
COMMITTEE SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAMBER CHOIR --
FIVE SURE MORE LIKE MY NAME IS
PEDRO ALBUM WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE LONG STANDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ORGANIZATION IT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION CELEBRATING OUR
FORTIETH YEAR.
AND OUR MISSION IS TO SEE A BAY
AREA WHERE EVERYONE HAS AN
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO CALL HOME.
WE ARE HERE TO THE IS PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX IT IS
ACTUALLY POSSIBLE TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA WHERE EVERYONE HAS AN
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE AND
PUBLICLY ON LAND COULD PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN MAKING THAT
HAPPEN.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT THOUSANDS OF ACRES
OF PUBLICLY OWNED LAND UP LIKE
BACON OR PARKING LOTS CAN BE
PRIORITIZED TO BENEFIT LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
THE WAY IT WILL DO THAT IS BY
CLARIFYING AND STRENGTHENING
CALIFORNIA SURPLUS LAND OCT.
THIS IS A FIFTY YEAR OLD LAW
WHOSE PURPOSE IS TO ENSURE THAT
SURPLUS PUBLIC LAND IS USED FOR
THE PUBLIC CRIED.
BY FROM BY PRIORITIZING THE LAND
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
MANY PRACTICAL OBSTACLES EXIST
TO ACTUALLY ENFORCING THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT WHICH THIS BILL
WILL HELP CORRECTIVE INCLUDING.
CREATING A STATEWIDE DATABASE OF
PUBLICLY OWNED LAND TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS SURPLUS AND
WHAT IS NOT.
CLARIFY WHAT IS SURPLUS WHAT IS
NOT AND IMPROVING THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW BY GIVING
A TO THE OVERSIGHT OVER IT.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL AND DILIGENT WORK BY
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF OVER ON
THIS BILL OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS A TWO WEEKS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE SIXTY
PLUS AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
INCORPORATED HAVE ACTUALLY
GREATLY STRENGTHEN THE BILL --
AND SO WE THOUGHT WE WOULD LIKE
FOR WE WOULD LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
FOR TODAY SO THAT THE STATE CAN.
CAN LIVE UP TO ITS PROMISE THAT
IT MADE OVER FIFTY YEARS AGO THE
PUBLIC LAND TO BENEFIT THE
PUBLIC GOOD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESEARCHING JUST FEELS LIKE IT'S
BEEN TWO YEARS SO.
OKAY.
MA'AM -- WE WELCOME YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING YOUR FIRST
AND LAST ORGANIZATION TO
MINISTER FOR SOURCE.
THANK YOU I'M DIANNE LUTHER AND
I'M THE ADVOCACY MANAGER FOR E.
H. HOUSING.
WE'RE A FIFTY ONE YEAR OLD
NONPROFIT DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
BASED IN THE NORTH BAY WE HAVE
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TEN
PROPERTIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
HAWAII.
AND WE SERVE ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN OUR NINE
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS SO LOTS
OF EXPERIENCE WITH DEVELOPING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE NEXT MONEY
IS OBTAINING LAND -- IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
HAVE THE SPACE TO BE ABLE TO
COMPETE. FOR PUBLIC SLASH
SURPLUS LANDS AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SOLID
PROPOSALS THAT WILL BENEFIT THE
COMMUNITY.
IT WILL RELIEVE BLIGHT HELP
DEVELOP UNDERSERVED RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND REDUCE THE STATE
WIDE HOUSING GAP.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT
PROVIDING REVENUE -- TO
GOVERNMENT LANDOWNERS.
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF A WIN WIN THAT
WE'VE ENGAGED IN IS OUR PROJECT
AT HAMILTON MEADOWS IN NEVADA --
THAT WAS BUILT ON THE DE
COMMISSIONED HAMILTON AIRFORCE
BASE WE DEVELOP THE SITE INTO A
LOVELY FAMILY PERMANENT SUPPORT
HOUSING PROJECT WITH A HUNDRED
AND ONE UNITS.
SOME OF WHICH ARE FOR PEOPLE
WITH HIV AIDS.
ALSO AT HAMILTON WE DEVELOPED
EIGHTY TO SUBSIDIZE
HOMEOWNERSHIP UNITS.
ARE MORE RURAL EXAMPLE -- IS A
PROJECT THAT WE HAVE CURRENTLY
GOING ON THE OLD FORT ORD BASE --
WE HAVE AN ALLOCATION OF THE
STATE VETERANS HOUSING FANS AND
WE'RE EXPECTING TO DEVELOP A
HOUSING THERE FOR ABOUT.
SEVENTY ONE A HOMELESS VETERANS --
WEIRD YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS AND
ALL LEGISLATION THAT WOULD MAKE
THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
MORE FEASIBLE LESS EXPENSIVE AND
QUICKER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE BY SURE
WOULD LIKE TO COME CHECK OUT
THAT HOUSING IN HAWAII -- IS
WHAT HE JUST SAID SO I CAN BE
REACHED ALL RIGHT HEY THERE YOU
GO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HEY THERE WE GO YEAH HE SHOULD
BE COMING TO NEVADA WHERE YOU'VE
BEEN.
I AM HAPPY TO CHIP IN FOR A ONE
WAY TICKET.
HEY THERE YOU GO.
HERE YOU GOT A NICE.
NICE THANK YOU SO MUCH A SHOT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA
WELCOME MISTER BILLY -- FROM THE
APARTMENT SO SHE SHE PLEASE COME
FORTY BECAUSE OFFER THOSE ARE IN
SUPPORT.
TORY BUT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT IS THE ONLY
FOR MANY WITH WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY SILICON VALLEY AT HOME
AND TEAM G. PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE MORNING RAIN I
WENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING ON YOU LAWLER WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THIS WILL.
GOOD MORNING LET'S MONDAY WITH
CALIFORNIANS TRANSPORT I THINK
THOSE THINGS RAIN -- GOOD
MORNING BRIAN A GUEST ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
AND THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
RURAL HOUSING AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING. ONE
TÁI DAVID ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING THE
MORNING MADISON BY ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT.
LAST CALL.
YOUNGER WELCOME ANYONE WHO MAY
BE IN A POSITION TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR ANY TO
MAKE ROOM FOR TO FOLKS ONE OF
YOU CAN STAY THERE -- PLEASE
THANK YOU SO.
THANK YOU SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS WE HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE GONNA BE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES WE WELCOME IF YOU
DON'T MIND GIVING US YOUR FIRST
LAST ORGANIZATION -- ESPECIALLY
THIS WHO'S GONNA KICK US OFF.
SPECIAL DISTRICTS READ ROLE
RIGHT FLOOR SURE SIR WELCOME THE
OF TWO MINUTES.
WHERE MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ROUNDED BOSSY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF FIRST OF ALL I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE?
VERY THOROUGH ANALYSIS AS WELL
AS THE HARD WORKING AMENDMENTS
TO A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX
THAT ACTUALLY DO RESOLVE SOME OF
OUR CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE FIRST HOUSE
TO REMOVE LEASES FROM THE BILL
WERE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND
RESOLVE THE CONCERNS FOR MANY
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE.
HOWEVER WE ARE WE DO REMAIN
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
UNTIL IT HAS BEEN AMENDED TO
EXAMPLE AND THAT SPECIAL
DISTRICTS NEED TO FILTER PUBLIC
PURPOSES.
THE BILL EVEN AS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED WOULD ONLY EXAMPLE AND
HAS BEEN USED BY THE AGENCY FOR
ITS OPERATIONS.
SPECIAL DISTRICTS FREQUENTLY
SELL LAND TO THIRD PARTIES IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE A PUBLIC
BENEFIT.
OR SERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY.
AS WRITTEN THE BILL WOULD MAKE
THESE LAND LAND TRANSFER SUBJECT
TO THE SURPLUS LANDS ACT.
AND IN A MOMENT MY COLLEAGUE
WITH THE HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
WILL PROVIDE SOME EXAMPLES OF
CRITICALLY NEEDED EXEMPTIONS.
ARTS SECOND CONCERT REMAINING
CONCERN WITH THE BILL IS THAT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX WOULD MAKE
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR AGENCIES
TO NEGOTIATE.
AND GET THE FAIR MARKET VALUE
FOR THEIR LAND.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
AGENCIES TO SEND OUT NOTICES
NOTICES AVAILABILITY PRIOR TO
PARTICIPATING NEGOTIATIONS.
THE BILL UNFORTUNATELY DOES NOT
PROVIDE A HELPFUL DEFINITION OF
NEGOTIATIONS AND IS THIS LACK OF
A BRIGHT LINE THAT WILL CONFUSE
AGENCIES ATTEMPTING TO COMPLY
WITH THE SURPLUS LANDS ACT.
I DON'T FLAT THIS IS
PARTICULARLY OF CONCERN AS AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX PENALIZES
AGENCIES WHO FAIL TO COMPLY WITH
THE SURPLUS LANDS ACT.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
AGENCIES IN VIOLATION WOULD PAY
A FINE OF UP 250% OF THE LAND'S
VALUE.
THIS IS INCREDIBLY PUNITIVE AND
EXPOSE A SMALL SPECIAL DISTRICTS
THE RISK OF INSOLVENCY IF
THEY'RE UNABLE TO PAY THE FINE.
MORE LIKELY THESE PROVISIONS
WILL SIMPLY DETERMINE YOU
SPECIAL DISTRICTS FROM DISPOSING
OF THE LAND AT ALL RATHER THAN
RISKING THE PENALTIES IMPOSED BY
THE BILL.
THE SELECTION LEAD TO LESS
PUBLIC LAND BEING DEVELOPED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ACROSS THE
STATE. FOR THESE REASONS WE DO
REMAIN RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT DISCONTENT AT
NOT AT ALL BE RUDE YOU HAVE TO
GO VOTE EDUCATION.
ON YOUR TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM ORANGE
COUNTY.
AND WE'RE GOING TO TRACK DOWN
SENATOR HERTZBERG -- AS WE ARE
IN NEED HIM TO COME VOTE AS WELL.
I APOLOGIZE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
TWO MINUTES IN A I DON'T MEAN TO
WALK OUT ON YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
IN BREAKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS ALSO HERE.
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
UNFORTUNATELY THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD SPECIFICALLY REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION WERE NOT INCLUDED
IN THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
I HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS ARE
FAIRLY UNIQUE AS MOST SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ARE HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS TEND TO SELL OR LEASE
THEIR LAND SPECIFICALLY FOR
HEALTHCARE PURPOSES THAT ARE
NEEDED IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
I'M FOR EXAMPLE WE DO HAVE A
DISTRICT IN MOUNTAIN VIEW THAT
HAS A PIECE OF LAND THAT THEY
ARE CONSIDERING IN THE FUTURE
BUILDING A HOSPITAL ON IF AND
THEY DON'T DO THAT THEY HAVE HAD
INTEREST FROM OTHER HEALTHCARE
ENTITIES.
IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO BUILD A HOSPITAL THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO FIRST
OFF RIVER HOUSING AND GO THROUGH
THE LONGER PROCESS IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO GET TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY CAN THEN NEGOTIATE WITH
ANOTHER PUBLIC ENTITY OR ANOTHER
HEALTHCARE ANTI. TO BUILD THE
HOSPITAL -- ADDITIONALLY A LOT
OF OUR DISTRICTS INCLUDE NON
MONETARY CLAUSES IN THEIR LEASES
AND IN THEIR SALES ON THEIR LAND
TO ENSURE THAT THE SPECIFIC
HEALTH CARE.
REQUIREMENTS -- ON THAT SITE
REMAIN.
AND ADDITIONALLY WERE CONCERNED
WITH THE DEFINITION OF PUBLIC
USE CURRENT IN THE CURRENT
AMENDMENTS.
AND THE BILL WOULD EXCLUDE.
LAND THAT'S USED FOR RETAIL OR
OFFICE DEVELOPMENT MANY OF OUR
DISTRICTS HAVE AND MEDICAL
OFFICE BUILDINGS THEY HAVE
RETAIL PHARMACIES THAT ARE ON
THEIR SITES.
THEY ALSO RECEIVE A PROFIT SOME
OF THEM DO -- SOME OF TEM ALSO --
OFFER THEIR LAND.
AND BELOW MARKET VALUE TO ENSURE
ACCESS TO SPECIFIC SERVICES BUT
THOSE THAT DO YOU HAVE A PROFIT
THOSE.
PROFITS AND THEN FIND THE REST
OF THEIR MISSION SO THE
ADDITIONAL HEALTH SERVICES THAT
THEY PROVIDE TO THEIR
CONSTITUENTS FOR FREE.
THOSE ARE PROVIDED BECAUSE OF
THEIR PROFITS AND SO THIS BILL
WOULD EXCLUDE IN THOSE LANDS AS
SURPLUS LANDS.
I'M AND THEN LASTLY I JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THE EXPANDED
DEFINITION IN LOCAL AGENCY
THAT'S IN THE BILL THAT WOULD
APPLY TO OUR PUBLIC AND
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE THAT LOCAL
THEM TH HAVE NONPROFITS
ATTACHED TO THEM AND WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF THIS DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE A NONPROFIT.
THIS BILL WOULD THEN REQUIRE
THOSE NONPROFITS TO COMPLY WITH
THE SURPLUS LAND ACT AND AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE WOULD URGE AND
ABOUT THANK YOU.
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES CESSATION
REPRESENTING PUBLIC POWER
AGENCIES AND WATER AGENCIES ONE
ECHO THAT THANKS TO THE AUTHOR
STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE SET
OF AMENDMENTS -- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IN LINE WITH SI
ESTAS COMMENTS THEY DON'T QUITE
GO FAR ENOUGH TO DRESS HOLLER
CONCERNS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS AUTHOR
AND IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE AS
WELL. TO FULLY RESOLVE OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
I MAY BE HE VICE CHAIR BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN YOU CAN GIVE A
WHOLE SPEECH BECAUSE DAMON
ASSOCIATION PLEASE CHRIS
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES UNFORTUNATELY IN
OPPOSITION THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ROSSUM
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN MARCOS
IN OPPOSITION.
HI JESSICA GEIGER WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES HERE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY ON BHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO WHEN EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO STAFF.
I OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
ALSO ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS UNDER
PROPOSITION.
CAROLINE OVER THE SOLANO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
OPPOSITION.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
AND ARE NOW TAKING TIME HERE FOR
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT --
OUR VIEWS TRACK WITH THOSE OF
ESPN'S ANYWAY [inaudible]
A TWEENER.
ALSO LET'S TRY TO HAVE THE
CITIES OF LIVERMORE DUBLIN
PLEASANTON AT SAN RAMON AND
DANVILLE ADD NO FORMAL POSITION
BUT WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
OF THE STAFF FOR AOTHER
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS IT'S
HELP THESE AMENDMENTS OF HELP.
TO CLARIFY SOME WORK WITH.
QUESTIONS AND WILL BE TAKING A
POSITION SAID.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR ANY OTHER WINNERS.
AND WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS SENATOR
WIENER -- AND MOVE THE BILL --
OUR THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
WORK IN ANOTHER.
SEVERAL OTHER SURPLUS LANDS --
BILLS ARE GONNA BE I KNOW
WORKING ON THEM AND HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND I KNOW WILL.
IF NOT NOW THEN OVER THE SUMMER
WILL HARMONIZE EVERYTHING -- I I
THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT WE
MAKE OPTIMAL USE OF THIS VERY
LIMITED RESOURCE THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA LANDS AND WE HAVE A
LOT OF PUBLIC AGENCIES WHO.
ARE THEY MAY HAVE LANDED THEY
WILL NEED THAT'S ONE THING BUT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT -- MANY PUBLIC
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA -- I WANT
TO USE THE WORD CORD BUT HOLD ON
THE LAND THAT THEY'RE NOT USING --
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE FACILITATE --
THE USE OF THE LAND ON AS WE SEE
THIS EXPLOSION HOUSING COSTS AND
THIS EXPLOSION IN THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO WERE LIVING IN THEIR
CARS AND LIVING IN SHELTERS AND
LIVING IN TENTS AND CHILDREN WHO
ARE HOMELESS -- WE NEED TO DO
MORE -- AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR -- AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN COME TO A RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
SENATOR WINNER -- REMEMBER
CHIANG EYEBROW PROBABLY WANTED
TO STOP ARE YOU THE OPPOSITE
MAYBE TO HAVE SOME SOME
DISCUSSION.
I REALLY LIKE THE IDEA OF USING
SURPLUS LAND I REMEMBER GETTING.
CONSTITUENTS COMING AND HEY WHAT
ABOUT GOVERNMENT LAND IT JUST
KIND OF SITTING THERE -- THEY
WERE KIND OF GETTING A THAT --
WONDERFUL DISCUSSION OF LOCAL
CONTROL AGAIN AS BATTLE THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH A NUMBER OF BILLS
AND IN AND YOU'VE YOU'VE
ESTABLISHED PRETTY GOOD LIST OF
WONDERFUL AGENCIES AND
ASSOCIATIONS THAT ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL -- SO YOU'RE YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE PUSHING
AN AGENDA BUT WORK.
AT TOUCHING ON SOME SOME SERIOUS
NERVES.
AND SO WERE MY PROBLEM IS BEEN
IS THAT I LOOK AT A MAP OF ALL
THE PROPERTIES IN ORANGE COUNTY.
THAT THE STATE OWNS [inaudible]
BETTER.
VACANT AND AVAILABLE -- AS A
SUPERVISOR THE FUN I HAD TRYING.
TO GET PROPERTY FROM CALTRANS --
EVEN FOR CONSERVATION PURPOSES
WAS JUST LIKE IT NEXT TO
IMPOSSIBLE AND SO I'M JUST KIND
OF WONDERING WHY THE STATE WOULD
KIND OF IMPOSE ON LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES WHEN IS NOT DOING
A VERY GOOD JOB.
OF IT WITH ITS OWN SURPLUS
PROPERTY AND SO THAT'S WHERE I'M
TRYING.
TO THANK YOU YOU KNOW BUT HE YOU
KNOW DOCTOR HE'LL BY SELF KIND
OF A APPROACH THE IF WE COULD DO
A RIDE OURSELVES IS SACRAMENTO
THEN.
THEN WE CAN COME IN AND SAY LOOK
WE'VE DONE WE'VE GOT A MODEL BUT
I'M NOT SEEING THAT NIGHT SO
THAT'S WHERE I'M HAVING.
DIFFICULTIES YOU KNOW SO WE
WOULD HAVE A MUCH LONGER
CONVERSATION ABOUT CALTRANS -- I
I DID A BILL ON CALTRANS FOR SAN
FRANCISCO. TO ALLOW THE CITY AND
COUNTY TO LEASE. TEN DIFFERENT
PARCELS IN IN SAN FRANCISCO AT A
REDUCED MARKET RATE IT'S PROVED
VERY SUCCESSFUL WE ARE. TO THOSE
SITES HAVE ALREADY BEEN USED FOR
NAVIGATION CENTERS.
AND SO AGAIN THESE ARE --
FREEWAY ON RAMP SAID AND HE
WOULD YOU PROBABLY WOULD HAVE
DRIVEN BY THE MONOXIDE YOU COULD
DO ANYTHING THERE.
BUT NOW WE HAVE TO NAVIGATION
CENTER SERVING OVER TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE GETTING THEM OFF THE
STREET SO.
I I COULDN'T AGREE MORE THAT
WEEK WE SHOULD BE DOING MORE AT
THE STATE LEVEL.
HAVING SAID THAT WE DO HAVE A
FIFTY YEAR OLD LAW ON SURPLUS
PUBLIC LAND ON WHAT IT IS HOW
HOW WE SHOULD USE IT.
WE WEEK WE REINFORCE THE IDEA OF
MAKING IT AVAILABLE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WHEN I DID IT.
IN UNFORTUNATELY EVEN THOUGH YOU
HAVE THIS LAW STANDING ON THE
BOOKS YOU HAVE.
I JUST NUMEROUS AGENCIES WHO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO FIND
DIFFERENT WAYS TO CIRCUMVENT THE
LAW SO SAID TO ME IF THIS IS
LESS ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL.
AND IS ABOUT TIGHTENING IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN ENFORCE
A FIFTY YEAR OLD STATE LAW --
WITH ALL RESPECT TO THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
I KNOW THE SPONSORS MY OFFICE
WE'VE ASKED FOR AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD GET THEM OFF -- THEIR
PARTICULAR AMENDMENT WOULD
BASICALLY EXEMPT THEM SO -- THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GIVE US ANY
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD -- WOULD
TAKE AWAY THEIR OPPOSITION EVEN
THOUGH IT'S BEEN REQUESTED FOR
FOR WEEKS AT THIS POINT.
IN THE AMENDMENT THAT THE
PROPOSED AGAIN IS BASICALLY AN
EXEMPTION IT SOUNDS SOUNDS LIKE
IT'S NOT BUT THAT'S REALLY WHAT
IT IS.
SO -- UNFORTUNATELY YOU KNOW WE
BELIEVE THAT THE SURPLUS LAND.
REALLY -- LAWS SHOULD BE
FOLLOWED THE SHOULD BE
CIRCUMVENTED THIS AGAIN JUST
HEIGHTENS EXISTING LAW DOES
PROVIDE SOME GREATER
CLARIFICATION.
AND AGAIN JUST ECHOING.
MY MY SENATORS COMMENTS AROUND --
IN THE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- WE WE DEFINITELY NEED
THIS LAND WHEN IT'S NOT BEING
USED FOR FOR THE HOUSING.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
ON CALTRANS PROPERTIES GOING
INTO THIS YEAR.
I CAN GIVE YOU SOME TIPS ABOUT
HOW TO DO THAT BECAUSE IT
DEFINITELY -- WASN'T EASY AND
WORKING WITH CALTRANS CAN AT
TIMES BE VERY CHALLENGING BUT
LOOK LET'S LET'S GO WORK ON
THOSE.
SITES IN YOUR DISTRICT NEXT
RIGHT AFTER WE WE GET DONE WITH
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH INTEREST YOUR
WOULD LIKE TO RECEIVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CENTER TARA.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT JOHN.
I SUPPORT YOUR EFFORTS IN.
IN THEORY IN CONCEPT -- I A CVS
SHOULD BE TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE --
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I ATE I ATE
I THINK IT POSES A LOT OF ISSUES
FOR MY REGION IN THE DISTRICT
THAT I REPRESENT.
AND YOU KNOW I'VE RECEIVED A LOT
OF OF LETTERS OF OPPOSITION FROM
THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA.
FRESNO COUNTY MOSQUITO AND
VECTOR CONTROL DISTRICT KERN
COUNTY CEMETERY DISTRICT TO
LEARN MUSKET ABATEMENT DISTRICT
TO LARRY PUBLIC CEMETERY.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON AND I
THINK THAT -- IT GOES TO SHOW
THAT THAT -- AT A WILD THERE'S
THERE'S GOOD INTENTIONS AND AND
IS THIS THIS BILL WILL HELP
ADDRESS -- ISSUES AND CONCERNS
AT THAT MAYBE FIND OUT IN THE
DISTRICT YOU REPRESENT THERE'S A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT ARE PRESENTS
FOR THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT -- AND SO WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TODAY I WILL BE OPPOSE
IN THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND GOOD VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ON IT
JUST AGAIN JUST TO REITERATE
WHAT I SAID EARLIER -- AGAIN
THIS IS TRYING TO REINFORCE OUR
STANDING LAW.
THAT UNFORTUNATELY.
PEOPLE HAVEN'T BEEN FOLLOWING
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S UC'S
LARGEST OPPOSITION -- THAT THERE
HAS BEEN -- MANY OF THESE
AGENCIES HOLDING ON TO
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF LAND THAT
REALLY COULD BE.
THE BETTER USE ELSEWHERE I THINK
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO GET THEM TO
THE FOLLOW EXISTING STATE LAW
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
FROM MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
CURRENCY NINE MEMBERS WE DO HAVE
A MOTION BY CENTER WIENER THE
MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED
HOUSING.
MR SOMEONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE AGAIN JUST THAT
THANK YOU FOR YOU IN YOUR
COMMITTEES PURCHASE RESPECT FAST
WRAPUP THANK YOU SO MUCH WHAT
TAKE MOM SAY THANK YOU SEE
NUMBER HIS TEAM.
WERE SITTING GIVEN THE
OPPOSITION AS WELL -- IN FOR THE
OPEN COMING IN FOR WORKING WITH
US AS WELL.
THIS IS A DO PASSES AMENDED TO
HOUSING.
IT'S SAYING JUST ROLL CALL
PLEASE WARRIOR HI WHY I'M MORE A
LOT.
MORE LOCK NO BELL HERTZBERG
RICARDO.
RICARDO NOW NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO WINNER.
WIENER AYE. TWO THREE TWO THREE
CURRENTLY THERE IS A TWO THREE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN
AND WE WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE-WE ARE GOING TO GET OUR ACT
TOGETHER GET ORGANIZED SEARCH
FIGURE OUT WHERE OUR VOTES ARE
AT AND WE'RE GONNA.
BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU WE ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE HEIGHTENED
CENTER HERTZBERG DOWN
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
PLEASE IN GERMAN YES A LITTLE
BIT OF HOUSEKEEPING.
JUST LIKE CENTER NIELSEN IN
CENTER WHERE LIKES MORE COWBELL --
WE HOPE THAT YOU ENJOY MORE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE WE'RE
GONNA OF AN AFTERNOON EDITION.
OF GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE HERE
TODAY -- IT'S IT'S QUITE
EXCITING.
CONGER NAIL IS THRILLED -- SO
HERE'S HOW IT'S GONNA WORK WE'RE
GONNA.
COME BACK AT TWO FIFTEEN RIGHT
TO KEEP THINGS EXCITING OR WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO ROOM -- THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE BETTER COFFEE IN
THAT ROOM -- SO AS WELL.
SO THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE A TO
FIFTEEN BUT WE'RE GOING TO ADD
THIS DINNER NIELSEN CENTER
WINNER IN CENTER HERTZBERG ON TO
THE BILLS ARE GOING TO TAKE A
BRIEF. TWO MINUTE BREAK.
UNTIL WE GET ASSN HER TADO ON
AND WE'RE GONNA GET EVERYBODY ON
WHO'S HERE.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA -- BRING
SENATOR BAIL SENATOR BAIL IN A
TO FIFTEEN SERVICING AND HAVE
YOU HERE WE'RE GONNA HOLD
EVERYONE WHO'S HERE NOW BRING
EVERYBODY UP ON THE VOTE.
THEY WERE GONNA RECONVENE AT TWO
FIFTEEN WITH SENATOR ABOUT WE'LL
BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU AS A
CENTER HER TITLE I WILL BE BACK
MOMENTARILY
.
WHAT'S YOUR PATIENCE AGAIN JUST
WANT.
TO BE CLEAR SO WE'RE GONNA ADD
EVERYONE WHO IS HERE ON TO THE
VOTE THEN WE'RE GONNA COME BCK
AT TWO FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE IN SENATOR BELL WILL BE
JOINING US OUT FOR THE AFTERNOON
EDITION ON THOSE VOTES.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB ONE THIRTY SIX
THIS MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE PREPARATIONS
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
NINE CHESTER TAKEN AWAY.
HERTZBERG ENTRETANTO YOUR TOTAL
ICE.
AT SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE MEMBERS
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWO THIRTEEN
MOTION TO PASS YOUR PREPARATIONS
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
LANCHESTER.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE HER
TITLE.
TOTAL AYE SEMINAL. SEVEN EIGHT
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE NOW
CLOSED IN THE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWO SIXTY
THREE MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
FIVE ZERO MISSING CHESTER
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HER CONNELL.
YOUR TOTAL I SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
VOTE THE BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE ITEM FOR AB
THREE FIFTY SEVEN MOTION DO
PASSES AND APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO MISSILE IN
CHESTER WIENER.
WIENER ON THE GOOD AT SEVEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT WERE CLOSE
LITTLE ITEM FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THROUGH ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY.
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN IN
BERMAN EQUALITY CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO MISSING CHESTER WIENER.
WIENER I'M FINE [inaudible] FIVE
ZERO THE TOOL FOR THE BUILDING.
THE BILL SALE.
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN FIVE ZEROS
THE FINAL VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE AND ITEM
NUMBER.
FIVE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX GIVE ME ONE MOMENT
[inaudible]
CHANGING FROM.
ITEM NUMBER SIX EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE THE MOTION IS DO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS KERN VOTE
IS FIVE ZERO MISSILE IN CHESTER
WIENER.
WIENER I'D. SIX SIX OF OUT THIS
IS SIX ZERO THIS BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
WE'RE NOW ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN I NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY SIX
TEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS. TO
ELECTIONS THE CURRENT VOTE IS
ONE FOR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
NOW IT'S LANCHESTER.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
NO.
NIELSEN OKAY I WIENER.
WIENER NOW THAT IS A TWO FOUR
TWO FOUR ONE TWO THREE FOUR YEAH
THIS STORY WAS.
ALSO MISSING.
THAT VOTE IS TO FOR THE MOTION
FAILS RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
WE ARE CLOSING THE ROLE ON ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED ON ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX TEN MEMBERS ARE
NOW GOING TO BE MOVING FORWARD
ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHT A. B..
SIX EIGHTY NINE THIS MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR KERN
VOTERS THREE ZERO MISS LANCASTER.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I LUCIANO.
FOUR ZERO ALREADY KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN FOR NOW.
ITEM NUMBER.
NINE EIGHTY NINE FORTY EIGHT
MOTION IS DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS KERN VOTERS FIVE
ZERO MISSING CHESTER HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE WIENER.
WIENER ICE. SEVEN EIGHT ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO JUDICIARY THE CURRENT
VOTE IS THREE ZERO MISSILE.
MISCELLANEOUS WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THAT ROLE OPEN -- AREA AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
SUSPENSE IN YOUR LIFE ON A
WEDNESDAY THE TWENTY SIXTH OF
JUNE.
SO LAYS IN GERMAN THAT IT'S
GOING TO CONCLUDE -- THE MORNING
EDITION OF GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE [inaudible]
THEM.
I AM NUMBER ELEVEN SORRY IT WAS
NOT IN FRONT OF ME I APOLOGIZE
THAT'S MY BAD ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
SO SORRY MR HERTZBERG I DON'T
NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. [inaudible]
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX WITH THAT.
A A THEIR YES CHAIR EMERITUS SAY
PARDON ME HIGH DAM -- THE MOTION
IS DO PASSES AMENDED TO HOUSING
THE CURRENT VOTE IS TWO ZERO
THAT SEE OTHER CHAIR OF MERIT IS
WOULD LIKE TO VOTE -- TWO THREE
TWO THREE YEAH.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE. THREE
THREE THREE THREE WE GOT A HORSE
RACE GOING ON RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT BILL OPEN.
AGAIN WE WILL SEE FOLKS AT TWO
FIFTEEN WE HAVE THREE ITEMS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE DEALING WITH AT
352-152-1530 ONE NINETY ONE ITEM
EIGHT ITEM TEN IN ITEM.
ELEVEN THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THANK YOU MISTER
NIELSEN.
THANK YOU MISTER WIENER WE'LL
SEE A IN THE AFTERNOON THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE AT
WELCOME BACK LACY GERMAN A IT IS
THE AFTERNOON EDITION OF THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
THERE'S A GENTLEMAN IN FRONT OF
YOU WE HAVE FOUR WITH THREE
BILLS THREE BILLS ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT ITEM NUMBER TEN IN ITEM
NUMBER.
ELEVEN FIRST OF ALL I DO THINK
THAT WE HAVE IN ORDER TO GIVE
OUT HERE TODAY -- AND THAT AWARD
IS GONNA GO TO DEVELOP TODAY.
I IT IS IT IS THE INTERJECTED SO --
YEAH IT'S RICARDO LARA AWARD
TODAY IS HOW WE JUST WANT TO SAY
I YES.
THAT'S RIGHT -- WOULD YOU DO YOU
HAVE SOMETHING.
WELL WE'RE HERE.
THERE YOU GO.
I WOULD YOU HAVE AN ACCEPTANCE
SPEECH HERE TODAY -- MISTER WORD
WINNER.
BESIDES CASTING I LIKE I LIKE
AWARD SO ALL TAKE TO RECORD OR
IS THIS HE RAN A FOLLOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR IF YOU.
HIS LOOK.
AT WAYS. TO THE WATCH OUTLOOK SO
A THERE WE GO ALL RIGHT HERE WE
GO IS LANCASTER LET'S OPEN IT UP
ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB SIX
EIGHTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO
MISSING JUST ROLL CALL PLEASE
WELL.
I I LOW FIVE OH THAT BILLS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING ALL NOW LIVING ON
ITEM NUMBER TEN THIS IS AB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO JUDICIARY.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
SAN CHESTER [inaudible]
BELT [inaudible]
I THE BILL IS OUT FINAL VOTE
FOUR ZERO FOUR CLOSE THE ROLE.
FINAL ITEM TODAY'S ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN WE GOT A HORSE RACE GOING
SENATOR BAIL AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO HOUSING THE CURRENT
VOTE IS.
THREE THREE THANK CHESTER BELL
[inaudible]
I WELL I FOR FOUR THREE BILLS
OUT CLOSE THE ROLE.
IN GERMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE TODAY.
U. P. SHADE CENTER VAL --
HELPING US OUT ON THIS ISSUE HE
REALLY DID STRETCH ON THIS -- IN
GETTING BACK TO US.
I WE WILL BE BACK WITH YOU AT
NINE THIRTY PLEASE PLAN ON A
COMMITTEE THAT WILL GO TO ABOUT
TWO TWO THIRTY NEXT WEEK -- IN
PROBABLY EVEN LATER IN THE WEEK
AFTER THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
WE'RE ADJOURNED